[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement Reigns every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test Championship spits
in a row who will be this year's Blitz
King it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are excited to welcome coinbase as a
presenting partner of the speed Chess
Championship and to welcome you to our
second exciting match of the day between
Maxima shelagrav the Frenchman with
three names and the Indian Phenom nihal
sarin and I am excited to be covering
the match alongside Grand Master
Benjamin Buck you've got a hero shift
today Benjamin two matches how you
feeling
I'm feeling pretty good Diane we started
the match earlier was a pretty dominant
victory for Magnus Carlsen but die in
this match right here is promising to be
an absolute Thriller we've got nihal's
horn against Maxine vasilograph matches
like these are the reason that people
get so excited so pumped about the SEC
we'll be diving uh into all the
specifics in particulars of this match
shortly but first let's dive into the
particulars of the bracket we've had
some incredible Marquee matchups already
in the book sikara Nakamura Benjamin
taking care of business we've had a lot
of blowouts including a blowout this
morning as Carlson squashes janapamnushi
with an incredible bullet performance
don't for sure yet uh Carlson put a very
impressive performance on the board but
yeah here between nihal and MPL they're
going to decide who will face Hikaru in
the semifinals I think it's going to be
a close one they they uh they're very
evenly matched extremely evenly matched
I think everybody is expecting a super
close match hikaranakamura man
yesterday's performance against Fabiana
caruana was a typical Hikaru Nakamura
display so well-rounded and right now
Hikaru and Magnus definitely displaying
the best form of anybody in the SEC
although mvl definitely competed uh with
his performance in his first match okay
let's dive into the specifics of the
match that we have today uh Benjamin
we're thrilled to have Deloitte leader
in their field as the official Data
Insights partner for the speech has
Championship their dedication to
Excellence aligns perfectly with the
chess.com mission to grow the game in
the sport of Chess let's dive into our
Deloitte game analytics this is page one
what jumps out to you Benjamin
Robert Johnson to me is that they're
very close in their Chelsea
compilerating we see that nihal has a
rating of 3200 and mvl just below 31
31.85 also mvl has a lead in their head
to head in the bullet they're much
closer but dying we know that nihal has
been getting better every single year
yeah uh all of these stats need to be
taken to the grain of salt especially
with two players who haven't faced each
other as many times and when you look at
their Peak chess.com Blitz and bullet
ratings that starts to tell a slightly
different story mvl might hold a current
lead in their head to head but let's
take a look at page two of our Deloitte
game analytics those Peak Blitz and
bullet ratings for knee-haul are
something else and he has cemented
himself Benjamin definitely as one of
the top online players he's so hard to
hard to bring down he's so fast and he's
so well-rounded as a blitz player
and I'm sure he's got the good openings
he's got a good middle game good tactics
and a good end game as well he's also a
great time scrap that Scrambler and
that's why he's got such a high peak
Blitz rating of 3277 and also his bull
rating die at 3 400 is just out of this
world it really is and how many times in
the SEC have we seen you know Newhall
pull out lost positions with one second
on his clock I mean the Wizardry that he
puts on display is something else but
mvl not to be outdone our smarter chess
prediction calls for an extremely even
match and for the first time I'm going
to wholeheartedly agree with this
prediction 14-14 smarter chess
predicting and over time affair today
Benjamin I don't really see how anybody
could disagree with a prediction for an
even match
this one is going to be close from Diane
I think mvl might have an edge in the
blitz I'm supposed to fight and three
percent portions he is the better
classical player so the longer the more
time on the clock the more he should be
in favor but nihal he is such a beast
and bullet he's so good in time
scribbles so I think he is looking to
describe to strike there I agree I think
if you're a nihal and you're
strategizing for maximizing your chances
of success you want to go into the
bullet with a tied match I don't think
nihal Minds that as we take a look at
the 19 year old Indian Grandmaster the
blitz wizard
nihal sarin both of these players are
really easy to root for they're super
classy uh they've been around the block
for many many years now and both of them
so experienced in the SCC and inihals
case in the jscc which he has won on
several occasions
man this is going to be a great match
Benjamin I'm I'm really excited for this
yeah no I'm excited this whole day and
what's impressive is that we're talking
about nehal like he's a veteran but he's
only 19 years old but like I said he's
been around he's got some gray hair you
know the grizzled the grizzled knee-hals
already you know he's yeah he's had
years and years of experience under him
but that's the crazy thing about modern
chess he could be 19 years old and it
honestly feels like he's been in the SEC
and he's been dominating chess.com
online tournaments forever and part of
that is because it has been you know
five or six years since Disney Hall has
established himself as one of the
fastest and most accurate players on the
site mvl hasn't played quite as much
Benjamin recently
but he is still so good in the SEC
he for sure is in 2020 he took down
Magnus Carlson in the semifinals and
let's look at their uh here we have
nihal sir let's see how he made it into
the scorer finals he beat
he beat Alexi serrana and he had an
average accuracy of 90.7 dire what do
you make with that yeah average accuracy
over 90 that's understandable in the
five plus one segment but remember this
is the cumulative accuracy over the
whole match over 90 percent including
the bullet he had some brilliant moves
he had very few blunders when you
consider the total number of games
played single digit blunders and Alexi
Serrano played an amazing match as well
which makes nihal's convincing Victory
all the more impressive it seems like
everybody's in good form this year uh in
the SEC which make these blowouts so
unreal but speaking of blowout's
Benjamin mvl was not to be outdone in
the first round his match against gukesh
after that first Mouse slip where gukesh
blew a winning position he didn't look
back
no and after that mvl just crushed him I
think it was the first game he took a
5-0 lead and didn't he even have a seven
game win streak Daya he crushed good
cash in the five plus one portion with a
seven point margin and in the other time
controls he was dominant as well and I
think these two players as we take a
look at Maxim there on camera the games
should be starting momentarily they have
different styles mvl definitely with the
more tactical opening repertoire he's
known for his night orfs one E4 with
white nihal likes to dodge a lot of the
mainline Theory particularly I think
with the white pieces Benjamin he's
shown a proclivity for openings like the
London system uh he likes the the berry
system of the jababa London as well uh
and with black you know he likes his his
perks and his moderns and he really
mixes It Up Normally in SCC mattress so
I'm curious what we're gonna see uh in
the opening phase
yeah so we really have a clash of styles
here Diane Maxim he plays chess like a
mathematician he's very principled with
white he plays E4 plays all the main
lines in every Mainline and with black
like he said he defends himself with a
knight off with a grunefeld and niho he
is probably gonna jump around is he
gonna play the London maybe B3 systems
let's not forget that MPL is a 2021
World Blitz Champion so he knows what it
takes to win he most certainly does and
in his first match against kukash we did
see our share of Sicilians but he was
also mixing it up he was playing uh with
with white one E4 and I think we're
gonna see a lot of e4s from mvl but with
black he actually played some Karo khans
and he did pretty well in them so it's
not like mvl can't play anything else uh
he knows a lot of different openings so
I think he's going to adjust based on
what nihal brings to the table today
yeah and I'm sure I would be uh I'll be
surprised if nihal goes into Mainline
Group Health Theory also I don't think
he he's really an E4 player so be
surprised to see a knight off on the
board as well I think we're gonna see D4
by by nehal maybe like a London system
or like a tourist system something like
that or all these setups with uh with
beef B3 so I'm curious to see what's
going to happen I'm curious as well uh
we're getting the players set up so the
games should be beginning uh momentarily
here but uh before they do let's take
one more look at the bracket and talk a
little bit about the relative form that
the players have displayed if you're
just joining we remind you that Hikaru
Nakamura is into the semi-finals as is
his main rival Magnus Carlson who will
face off against Wesley so in the first
semi-final Hikaru will face the winner
of this match that we're watching right
now today between nihal and Maxime
Benjamin do you think hikar was looking
at this match do you think he prefers a
particular opponent between these two or
does he not care
well I literally don't care Donna I mean
I'm gonna win anyway no I mean of course
he uh yeah he's played both players a
bunch he's played nehal he's played MPL
I think he's looking forward to play uh
both opponents and uh but either way I
think Hikaru should be quite a hefty
favorite
yeah I agree completely he has defeated
nihal sarin in previous SEC matches he's
played both mvl and nehal sir and he's
no stranger to it I wanted to ask you
about the first match uh Benjamin you
commentated uh Magnus Carlson's crushing
victory over yondapomnishi were you
surprised at how much of a of a blowout
it ended up being
and then ended up being quite a blower
to be honest in the beginning Magnus
admitted to this himself in the
interview he wasn't that stable like Jan
got off to a lead in a match it could
have even been two points but after
Magnus equalized the match he seemed to
be in full control soon after that he
took the lead and it was going to be the
question like with how many points he
was he was going to win he always had a
two to four point lead going into the
bulletin in the bullet it was just an
absolute blower
I think the the key word there is just
control and wire to wire Victory it's
what's scary about magnus's form this
year in the SEC is that even when it's a
quote-unquote close match you almost
feel like the blowout is going to happen
any second and then it does right they
reach it's only a matter of time in in
this match it was the bullet where
Magnus really separated himself in his
match against vidit it was the end of
the three plus one portion and also the
bullet where he built up that double
digit lead if you're just joining us and
you don't know what the SEC is all about
let's fill you in on the format and the
particulars of how each match works the
players accumulate points until time
runs out the scoring is standard there's
one point assigned per Victory a draw
means half a point for both players and
obviously a loss results in zero points
if the match is tied at the end of the
allotted three hours there will be four
games of one plus one if that ends in a
2-2 tie as we saw in Wesley so's match
against alireza ferrugia and arm
Armageddon will be played where the
players bid on their times in an
Armageddon black gets draw odds so if
the game ends in a draw and the player
with black wins and I think Armageddon
is not unlikely in a match with players
this evenly matched here are the time
splits we've got an hour and a half of
five plus one to head off the match
followed by an hour of three plus one
and then half an hour of bullet one plus
one to end the match with a one second
increment in all of the games but the
most interesting thing Benjamin the only
time that we might get a no increment
game is if we go all the way to an
Armageddon
yeah it's pretty interesting Diane
normally we read of this car like okay
if it's tied there's a four game mini
match then there's an Armageddon and
then we're like hey well that never
actually that never happened right but
it actually happened in that match
between Wesley and Ellie Russell that
one went down to the wire so it's uh
yeah I think this one can also go down
to the wire would be of course an
absolute Thriller if it comes down to
overtime as well but since these two are
so evenly matched I think could easily
happen and of course we're not
guaranteed a close match you know
sometimes you get evenly matched players
and you still get a blowout you know why
does that happen it happens when one
player is in Superior form it happens
when one player pulls away early so I
think for both of these players but
particularly for nehal because I think
mvl is thinking of the five plus one as
the segment where he really wants to
build up that maybe two or three point
cushion I think the the closer you get
to the bullet the more we get into
nihal's territory do you think mvl
shares that vision of the match
yeah and I think so too Diane I think he
should try to take a lead in the in the
in the longer time controls in the five
plus one and by the way as we speak we
are off with move one Knight of three
from nihal and Diane I just wanted to
ask you real quick if you had to pick
one player to win this match who's your
pick
man you're putting me on the spot I I
feel like both of these players have
displayed such incredible form just
because we've got half an hour of bullet
I'm gonna have to go knee-haul by a tiny
bit but I really think it's going to
come down to the last couple of games
right so in that case I'm gonna go with
mvl like I said before he's a 2021 World
Blitz Champion yeah also he crushed good
cash but with a margin of 13 points Niha
only only won by six points so because
then I'm gonna go with MBL
that's a totally fair prediction
um I think we're gonna find out a lot
based on the form that these players
display in the first 90 minutes well as
expected nehal playing his sort of
Knight F3 offbeat ish type openings and
we have I think more of a Carlsbad
structure generally the white Bishop is
on G5 in these positions here New Hall
has positioned his dark Square Bishop on
F4
right and we see mvl expanding on the
queen side with move B5 B5 weakens the
ball in C6 but I it does make sense as
now your queen can go over to B7 and
otherwise it's always going to be stuck
here on seat A4 also a nice move gaining
some space on the queen side yeah the
Knight comes out to D7 Rook C1 threatens
the prosaic Knight takes B5 forcing mvl2
fianchetto his Queen but B7 is a pretty
good score for black screen it's kind of
in the bushes and most importantly it
supports that backward Pawn on C6 and as
long as that pawn is alive Black's Pawn
structure on the queen side is quite
healthy
exactly at some point MPL would love to
go Knight B6 to C4 you do have to move
B3 at some point for what for white to
stop it but that's going to open up the
A4 4 black so I would think white is a
very slight attribute to the Moon
Black's pretty solid I do like this
Moonlight turbineal to kick the bishop
of this active diagonal all of these top
players are so good at using both sides
of the board to their advantage the
action has been happening on the queen
side with Black's expansion but nehal
says I haven't forgotten about the king
side either I think he's trying to
situate his Knight on F5 and Garner the
bishop pair the eval bar not a big fan
of Knight B6 is it because Knight F5
enables white to grab that Bishop pair
I like to move 95 by nihal but the evil
bar doesn't it drops quite uh quite a
bit down maybe I don't know yeah I was
gonna say maybe E4 but it doesn't seem
that convincing either of the knights
often hanging I like this move I mean
you get the bishop pair on the other
hand Blake gets rid of this passive
Bishop on E6 he still is an active
Bishop potentially on the darshan and
Knight C4 could come any moment now
yeah Knight C4 is asking to be played
you called it if white is forced to play
the move B3 then ideas like Bishop E7 to
A3 become possible the a file opens okay
nihal has the bishop pair
congratulations but how do you continue
improving that Bishop on F5 it looks
pretty but it's not really controlling
any crucial squares and I think because
of that nihal brings it back to home
base on D3
it drops the bishop back to D3 MPL could
consider Knight C4 but now nihal could
even take you don't really want to take
the with the B Pawn as that leaves the
A4 Pawn hanging you could take with the
d-pawn it gives wine more of a free hand
in the center but in return for that
black gets a nice clamp of Pawns on the
queen side but mvl plays the move Queen
E7 you're indicating E4 do you think
that's a likely move that will likely
lead to an isolated Queen Pawn structure
as nihal actively considering E4 uh but
I think he's taking it in a different
direction with B3
it'd be three very logical move make
sure the Knight can not jump to C4 now
at some point I think he's gonna play
Move Like 92 to clear the C file for his
rook and put pressure on the pawn on C6
combined with Queen C2 because with
Queen C2 you can no longer defend the
pawn with a move like Roxette as there
will be five yeah that Bishop was on F5
it might return to F5 with great effect
the C6 Pawn is the only target it's
Black's only weakness and it makes a lot
of sense uh to pile up on that pawn with
your heavy pieces
right so I mean 92 makes a lot of sense
here for nehal he can also trade himself
but it slightly improves the placement
of the black queen queen F3 is a
possibility as well but then I don't see
a good defense after Rook A3 the pawn on
B3 also is a little bit tender and
that's one of the benefits of keeping
the queen on C2 you want your pieces to
be fulfilling both defensive and
attacking roles simultaneously the queen
on C2 it guards the B3 pawns it guards
the second rank so it takes the sting
out of blackstroke on A8 and it sets up
Bishop F5 I love the move Knight E2 I
think this is a big moment if nehal
finds 92 I think he puts serious
positional pressure on mvl but he's
taking a long thing here what might be
his reservation toward playing 92 maybe
it's Rook A2
I don't know yeah I guess there is
rookie 2 for black but is that really a
concern like you can maybe go Rook C2
try to trade out the Rooks he takes on
D6 himself I'm slightly surprised by
that decision die I to me 92 looks very
natural I think this is a bit of an
improved version for black I mean I
would still play Queen C2 with white
um and I would start with Queen C2 just
to prevent the possibility of
blackstroke diving into A2 which is not
a scary move from an attacking
perspective it's annoying because it
prevents Queen C2
the idea
right in case black takes you now takes
for the night and after the cream moves
he can go Knight C7 forking the two
Rooks now the evil bar is still in the
middle as after all those trades black
will have two knights why do I have a
rook and two pawns but this B Pawn isn't
too scary just yet so I think MPL should
not be too concerned no and and clearly
this is this is what nihal was spending
most of his time on he was trying to
assess uh the position after he grabs
one of the Rooks which he doesn't have
to do immediately but I don't really see
the point in procrastinating
um I would just decide already you know
which you're gonna take I would probably
take actually which Rook would you take
or would you take a rook at all
it's a great question though I don't
know I think the rook and Aid is pretty
well placed so maybe you take an E8 and
if black recaptures The Rook as a little
less well placed on E8 you can recapture
with a knight or thinking of Knight D6
and Knight of six perhaps that is a good
way for black to rewrite their pieces
great call and I think nihal thought in
a along exactly the same lines instead
Enfield takes back with the Rook so he's
sort of clamping down on some of these
Central squares nehal could dive into C7
with his Rook an idea that kind of
parallels uh Black's earlier possibility
of Rook A2 and that's exactly what he
does if you're in the hall here you want
to maximize the activity of your heavy
pieces and you do not want under any
circumstances for blacks Knights uh to
start running amok uh and find good
squares in the center so Knight f8
Knight E6 could be a way for mvl to
improve the placement of his Knights
right but I love the move queen of C2
now 96 came you met with Rook C8 for
Nihao it would be great to trade of one
pair of Rooks as then the Blackbird can
no longer do any damage and he can start
to infiltrate with it with his own heavy
pieces so let's see how mvl will deal
with this Rook saying for the moment is
not a threat as black can take and then
take on B3 don't really want to drop
that B2 B3 Pawn for free so we see MV
algon group B8 and Rook A1 by nihal he's
second the pawn but if you take I think
it's way too risky Daniels rookie is
coming in when nihal took on B5 I think
this is exactly what he had in mind a
situation where the activity of the
knights is curbed uh by the fact that
Black's eighth rank uh is weak and there
aren't any good squares for the knights
to jump onto meanwhile white is
establishing Piggies on the seventh Rook
a A7 is a huge threat and mvl has to get
active Pronto he does with Knight E4
Rook A7 Queen E1 check looks unappealing
for white maybe Neil should play King H2
preemptively to set up that threat of
Rook A7 then there is a check on D6 but
that check doesn't seem as dangerous it
can be blocked by G3
right G3 is there for y but maybe with
like H5 H4 is on the cards for black I
wonder exactly how this line goes so
let's say Okay seven you give a checking
each two does black just take here in
network of seven check and 94 is that
what mvl has in mind I think it is and I
think it's important that the Knight on
f8 guards the H7 Pawn so even in a
situation where white takes the pawn on
G7 black plays King h8 and can buy
himself some time to further his
attacking goals instead we see G3 by
nihal is he preparing King G2 and VL
responds with the same type of move G6
disliked by the eval bar
but what about Rook A7 outline because
Queen E1 can be met with King G2 and the
F2 Pawn is guarded but I can try 92 to
try to slide into F1 but maybe just
Queen D3 there Queen D3 or even Queen C1
White's got options in that position but
Neil doesn't have a lot of diamonds look
at this in 30 seconds
look at this if you go Rook a 7 Queen E1
King g292 you turn queen of one right so
we go Queen E3 and after 94 it might
seem like that would force repetition
this Rook takes F7 and you guard the F2
Pawn very important observation Rook
takes F7 will defend that pawn on F2 and
nihal goes for it this is classic
knee-hawk he's got 23 seconds the
position's still Ultra complicated and
yet I think he's got full faith in his
ability to sort through the
complications Rook a A7 he's threatening
the F7 Pawn will we see Queen E1 check
or will mvl double back and play the
defensive move Knight D6 Knight D6 there
still could be Rook takes F7 and queen
C7 what an idea
wow what a fine but instead empyokus 96
seconds
what is the idea don't you I think we're
about to find out nihal has to take on
F7 he's in too deep and he's trying to
figure it out frantically he takes
what is mbl's concept here Knight G5 oh
Brook takes H7 if you're taking there's
Queen G6 Rook takes H7 is winning three
seconds for knee-haul also good
is so good under time pressure but he
has to be careful because these top
players will find a way to punish you
will mvl take this Pawn on H3 guess
there's just King G2
I'm trying to figure out if Rook takes
G6 check is a threat but I actually
don't think so I think the knights are
guarding in that resulting position all
of the potential mating squares
Rook of Faith therefore by MPL but this
has a pretty set position White's got an
active rook in the seven H4 okay where
does the Knight go against back to E4
back to E4 and white has to be patient
because black has anchored himself to
the F2 Pawn King G2 and F3 might be what
the doctor ordered here instead we see
Rook D7 but MBL could infiltrate F3 here
with his Queen
right as the Knight can still hold with
none of it and nihal made them with 1.2
seconds oh my gosh we're back to A7 he's
just sort of biting his time the great
thing about nehal's position is that F2
is protected and black doesn't really
have all that many active ideas to stir
up complications nihal also has a b-pawn
that he could set in motion momentarily
exactly so let's see what mvl is going
to do for the moment Queen's hit is a 30
ghost queen of three with point six like
how does he do this point nine point six
point six again does MBL have nothing
he doesn't have anything it looks like
like you have a checking it too
no time if he if MPL can create one
thread I think you can trick Niha but I
don't see how to do it I've done that
I've tried this so many times and Neil
just pushing his spawn look at what he's
doing mvl has all of his pieces
surrounding White's King all he has are
empty checks Queen H1 King E2 six
seconds now for mvl and looks like he
has a couple accurate moves away from
winning his King is now in complete
safety on the queen side
but mvl also not getting along the clock
the king is sitting completely safe on
B2B and queen C8 and queen G4 was at a
Checkmate that was horse mate still not
so clear he's gotta go Queen B3 Knight
C3 that's it and you wiggle out of it
King C2 that's it yeah that's it you win
the Knight
a masterpiece in the first game by niho
this is vintage vintage nihal Star and
if you want somebody to get a sense of
him as a blitz player show them this
game
yeah he drops down to one second but he
just does not blunder he doesn't flag
and he finds the best moves like it's
incredible most players when they get
down you know most experienced time
scrambles they're good at kind of
keeping the status quo you know they're
good at making moves and not blundering
mate nihal actually furthers the causes
of his position he actually actively
tries to win the game with one second on
the clock he perceives all of the
threats and what I'm most impressed
thereby is his ability to walk his King
toward the center and the King side he
was surrounded by Knights and a queen
and he didn't care
yep he didn't care he didn't blunder
four he didn't blunder mate and that
people on idiot in the end the side of
the game here we see mvl going very
aggressive against the petrol with H5 H6
nihal just calmly plays him with H6
himself MPL I don't think second is a
realistic possibility here what about G4
and G5
that would be a write-up mpl's alley but
maybe you go like Knight F6 G5 and
Knight E4 you formed the queen in the
pawn and G5
yeah G4 Knight F6 is a problem maybe
that could be met with Rook G1 and
typically white wants to get rid of the
G Pawn uh to open up a file direct
Avenue toward black skin but a different
approach different approach taken by
Maxime as he centralizes his Knight we
might still see the black knight move
out of the way to guard the up five
square
right so Knight C5 stopping knife from
Charming here but now MPL goes F3
preparing that move G4 I guess he wants
to follow up with Rook to G1 and G5 I
think the problem in the last game Daya
was that mvl did not have any tricks I
think if there would be tricks for him
there would be a real possibility for
knee holder blonde but there was not
actually a single uh single bit of
counter play for envion that's why nihal
kept everything together all of the
squares were defended and speaking of
keeping things together nihal Dives his
Bishop into G5 engineering a series of
Trades I don't think black mines a queen
trade here that would definitely uh
reduce the possibility of a king side
attack almost down to zero we do have
that Queen trade I think we might see
the move C4 trying to bite into Black's
Pawn chain in the center
black takes also your own Bishop comes
to life mvl plays King C1 first making
sure that there's never a background
Checkmate also bring the king a little
bit closer to the center and perhaps the
move C4 now
I think C4 is is the clear clearly the
the only way to generate problems for
nehal instead mvl prioritizes
centralizing his own King but something
about this looks a little bit awkward to
me I can't put my finger on on what it
is
here I know C4 has really lost its
appeal as it would open up the default
and that is where your king is located
you can go Bishop to D3 but what are you
really gonna do you can go Pawn HX but I
think black's just going to keep it
close with the movie G6 and this h-pawn
can easily turn into a weakness now
nihal has a decision to make he can
trade his Knight for the bishop but is
that really the way to go Daya
yeah I'm not sure I think Knight A4 is
also possible that Knight on C5 does
have a lot of potential
um Knight takes D3 and C5 though is I
think a viable approach as well just
chase the Knight away away from the
center I think black has solved all of
his problems this looks like about an
equal end game but because we have a
peace imbalance I don't think it's
necessarily you know going to be a quick
draw
yeah I like to move C5 setting his
Center motion also giving the bishop a
little bit more room to move had he not
played the most C5 I think mvl was
looking at the move B4 to restrict black
spawn chain now we see the move F6 by
nihal placing his pawns on darks first
because he's the light Square Bishop are
we going to see H6 at any point by mvl I
don't think so instead we see the move
F4
smashing through Black's Pawn cocoon on
the king side
right so let's see what Neil is going to
do he can do a G4 but that would place a
Pawn on the light Square so you can also
keep the pawn here but why it's going to
take and then black will have double
isolated pawns it's a good question
whether mvl is going to go HX and I
think here the threat might be stronger
than the execution y can always keep
this ID on on tap I think after G4 you
just go Knight G3 and he will play it at
the right moment yeah I don't love the
move G4 here it definitely restricts the
mobility of the bishop nehal going for
all of the trade series exchanges on F4
which does give white much better
Prospect now for his Knight mvl taking a
pause here he's thinking about King
takes E1 and King F2 to keep the Rook on
H1 so that you can support the H6
breakthrough I I wouldn't overthink it
though I would take with the rook and
grab that open file and I think nihal
intends to put his Bishop on G4 Benjamin
maybe it's this Factor that's giving mvl
pause the fact that H5 is now a serious
Target
right H5 is a target with the pawn and
D5 is a serious Target as well the Nano
F4 can never be challenged as G5 is not
available there will always be Pawn
takes G6 and perhaps after Bishop to G4
you can now play the move d4 fix that
weakness on D5 which will always be
under pressure I think you should still
play the move d4 and he does and that
really disarms that Bishop on C6 which
is now consigned to a passive existence
staring at its own weakness on D5 maybe
rookiegate is what knee Hall intends
here who benefits in the event of a rook
trade hard to say but clearly mbl's in
the driver's seat now in this end game
right as a real kid it kind of reminds
me of that classic game between karpov
and Kasparov white will have a slightly
better Knight than the bishop which is
going to pass over here and the King
side has opened up a little bit so that
would potentially give mvl a pass for
his King
yeah that is a very very unpleasant end
game and the H5 Pawn is no longer an
attackable Target of course white could
support it with the g2 G4 but you want
to be careful about putting too many
pawns on light squares because that
g-pawn would then be attackable by
Black's Bishop from D7 so I think the
Knight on F4 is the star piece here for
mvl it's again a piece that's occupying
a defensive role it's defending H5 but
it's also seizing control of important
light squares in Black's territory on E6
and on juice and of course attacking the
D5 Pawn
exactly yeah I think you would rather
put your Pawn in G3 solidifying the the
Knight a little bit also that way you
get your Pawn off a light square and we
have to move rookie eight by Neil
Diamond what a decision actually Diane
what about this what if we take on E8 if
you recapture the king what about 96
attacking the pawn the only way to
defend it is king of Sam but then
there's 98 and we go into the spawning
game is that a drawer is wide winning
there and let me tell you if that's
exactly what Newhall just spent a minute
evaluating I think that pawn end game
has to be evaluated before you go for
this end game
and now mvl has to spend some time of
value but he played a little too quickly
I don't like the fact that he didn't
pause and consider the move 96 maybe he
missed Knight d8 but now that ship has
sailed and I think nihal might have a
fortress now
yeah that looked like a nice opportunity
as you can also walk your king of the
king side with Kingdom five maybe then
G5 at the right moment that was winning
Benjamin
yeah like normally mvl is the guy is the
type of guy to take his time there and
uh calculate it all the way through and
and execute the win but here it feels
like he's still better but is this
actually winnable that I am I think the
only plan is to get your king to H4 and
then push G5 and try to open up more
territory on the king side and
ultimately to infiltrate and win the G7
Pawn that's a very scary plan I think
the eval bar is only giving a modest
Edge but I would take that and toss it
in the trash under a minute for Newhall
this this is a Herculean defensive task
that awaits him in this end game
yeah for sure we saw in the last game
how he converted a winning position but
defending a worse position with no time
on the clock is a very tough task and he
would be under serious pressure another
plan for mvl would be to let's say go
Knight G2 king of 4 93 and move the
knight at five oh man that looks pretty
sexy as well he's got these two plans to
choose from that's why he's pausing King
G3 King H4 is one Knight back to G2 and
then King up to F4 93 Knight F5 is the
other both of them ultimately attacked
the same Target that G7 Pawn which right
now might seem unattackable but that's
why Knights are so good they're good at
jumping over obstacles and attacking
what they want to attack
right and the nice thing for black is
that these spawns are on darshus not on
the same color of the bishop however the
downside is that you cannot defend upon
if you attack the pawn with the Knight
it's simply going to be gone right if
you can only defend the light squares
that's exactly right and that is the
main limitation of the bishop as a
defensive piece
okay big big moment here mvl with two
distinct paths they're similar in their
ultimate Target and he goes for the
Benjamin Bach approach the Knight drops
back to G2 but does nihal have to keep
his pawns on the king side where they
are could he play some sort of crazy
move like F5 he goes G5 what a move
I like this move by nihal day and now in
case of H6 you can meet up with Bishop
to G6 G6 therefore was not good as after
each of the pawn simply promotes he's
giving mvl a protected passer but how do
you actually push it through
it's such a concrete move it's such a
difficult move for a newer player to
play because it looks terrible you're
giving white a protected passer on the
edge of the board that is like a dream
trump card but the problem is that white
likes a bishop anytime white plays H6
black plants his Bishop on G6 and this
is the definition of a fortress you've
got all the assets but you have no
direct way to win
right so let's see how MPL will try to
create some problems here maybe what he
can do is move his King over to the
queen side but I guess black can always
build a wall of Pawns with like B6 and
A6 there being said maybe if black takes
that uh defense then there's like A4 A5
to carve out some squares I think you
have to try that because trying to find
the right moment to play H6 is a losing
proposition there's no infiltration
points for White's Knight so I think MBL
has to lead his King to the queen side
it's definitely a draw objectively but
with 15 seconds if you can create
practical problems I still think you
give yourself a chance maybe drag
Black's King away from the center and
try to go like 97 and H6 in some
position I don't know as he drops his
Knight back to E3
but so King E6 here comes the king king
D2 King C3 I like this plan by MPL I
don't see how Neil I should defend you
can go King C6 but then the king is
pretty far away from all of the action
on the king side and there might be like
a knight of five to E7 jump at the right
moment maybe B6 and A6 your defensive
setup he goes the other way I think he's
trying to push F5 and create active
counter play himself this is actually
scary for mvl as well I mean you could
lose this if you go into deep on the
queen side and then beyond that down to
30 seconds
so let's see what he's gonna do knee
held down to four so King before makes a
lot of sense I'm sure it's the move he's
considering
H6 preventing F5
B4 b4o3
it's winning the hall is paralyzed
now here we see that nihal got a little
bit too long like the bishop over here
is completely sucking just go King B6
and push the pawn and black has got
absolutely nothing on the king side and
I want to draw attention Benjamin to
that Knight on E3 that is such a
perfectly placed piece because you're
stopping F5 and if you're stopping at
five black runs out of ideas King C5
this is an elementary win for ambul oh
he can even take the pawn yeah he's got
all the time in the world
okay here comes the king but you you
just push the Deep on and these two
passes are too much for black to handle
and mvl evens up the score he strikes
back and he strikes back with a model
positional game that was an equal end
game a bit of a frustrating game for
knee Hall it looked like he was on the
cusp of building a fortress but we know
who doesn't believe in fortresses he was
playing this morning
exactly yeah and so and uh nehal
switches it up now with a bit of a Joe
Bava london-esque setup with Knight of
393 and Bishop 2 F4 but die I think in
that game we started what nihal dropped
really low on time and because that he
wasn't quite able to defend so he should
be careful with his time management for
sure but I think that this will be a
theme throughout this match I think we
will see situa a lot of situations where
mvl has you know a minute or two on the
clock and nihal has just a couple of
seconds and nihal's ability to navigate
the complications uh in those low time
scenarios will be a deciding factor in
this match now this particular jababa
London system where the Knight heads to
B5 and drops back to A3 is one of
nihal's favorites he's really really
good at this line he understands a lot
of the ideas here I've lost a lot of
games on the black side of this type of
structure against nihal
yeah you might be wondering what is the
Knight on A3 doing but the 90 C7 is also
somewhat misplaced also the bishop G7 is
biting on granite very often Kings
Indian players would love to put their
Pawn on D6 to follow up with E5 but
right now this was passive the
bishop on B7 is passive as well and
White's Bishop on F4 has got a lot more
scope and that's why nihal can hope for
an edge here and now the position
resembles a traditional London in fact
if you saw just this position you would
never guess that the knight uh who
reached D2 in this Ultra roundabout
manner
exactly yeah you would want to know how
do how did these Knights end up on D6
and S6 normally they would be on let's
say C6 and F6
oh yeah that's a great point of course
the reason the Black Knight is on C7 has
to do with Knight B8 to A6 uh which was
necessary to guard a pawn that used to
be on C7 so it's almost like this game
is two games rolled into one and this is
the second stage but I I like White's
position all of his pieces are on the
sort of perfect textbook London squares
he's got the clamp on the E5 square and
that's what's so annoying about playing
this position for black you don't really
have any pawn breaks here you just kind
of have to shuffle your minor pieces and
it's not clear even how to do that
exactly yeah I don't know what mvl
should do here you can go Bishop A6 to
try to trade off the light Square
Bishops but nihal can now just play
Bishop the C2 he's ready to play 95 puts
on pressure in the center and on black
skin his Queen can slide over to F3 and
die I don't really see an active plan
for mvl here and he's down on the clock
maybe Knight C7 to E8 to F6 I've tried
that particular maneuver a lot uh
against nihal but but even if you get
your knight to F6 okay congrats you can
get your knight to E4 but but that
doesn't materially impact uh this
position in any way we see Queen C8 just
kind of a semi-waiting move I think
nihal might put his Knight on E5 and
continue improving
and there we go the Knight has landed on
E5 and we are struggling to come up with
a plan 96 is possible but you just slide
the bishop all the way back to H2 and
then what like I said you can move your
knight F6 but then well there's there
are really no active plans here for
black and that is why MPL is spending so
much time
of course the same question exists on
the other side White's piece is as
pretty as they are uh you know good
pieces as tarish that don't win new
games good moves when you games but it's
much easier for any Hall to keep
improving than it is for mvl to even
keep the status quo
right I like this move 96 so challenging
the bishop on F4 and once that Bishop
drops back to H2 now he can go Knight G5
at least his pieces are coming to life a
little bit more Queenie too by Neil
maybe now Bishop A6 as Bishop C2 is no
longer available great call Benjamin
Bishop A6 removes the linchpin of white
setup without the light squared Bishop
the E4 Square will be accessible
potentially to Black's Knights and it
feels like MPL has beaten back the kind
of first wave of nihal's attack I like
the trend of the game here for black
even though white is probably still
better objectively
exactly yeah he's traded off a passive
piece on on his other the passive light
Square Bishop provides active light
Square Bishop on D3 his Knight can
potentially jump into E4 I think the
edge though for white is the fact that
his Bishop H2 is probably still better
than the bish1 G7 which isn't doing a
whole lot it's 95 is more active and
also Black's Queen side can still be a
little bit tender
it most certainly can be uh you can
Envision in the long run ideas like Rook
A3 and Rook B3 the B6 pawn it is a
backward pawn and I think nihal might go
for the queen trade here and try to
change the nature of the position if mvl
captures with the queen which is not a
given but he just did and indeed we will
get another end game uh this one a lot
more pleasant for nihal than the one in
the previous game obviously
yeah it goes 93 pressuring that pawn on
C5 and dying he's also pressuring the
Knight on D6 so if you go Rook C8 I
think white would happily trade off the
bishop for the Knight and then go Knight
F4 and then the ball on D5 is simply
undefendable that's crazy and you all
your pieces are clustered around the
center and you can't defend you know
your your biggest Pawn on D5 so is
Knight B7 the way to play here for black
because white actually has two threats
right there's C5 which is hanging and
there's Bishop takes D6 which is a very
serious positional threat
right and he goes for your move Knight
to B7 there was also 94 but white can
pass just take and then F3 nehal goes
King to F1 bringing his King to the
center so now let's see what mvl is
going to do he still does not have an
active plan I mean you can move the root
back at some point but then you always
have to reckon with this move Bishop to
C7 and E5 for the moment is not
available nihal has done a good job of
accelerating his Pace in this position
and that's because he's so familiar with
this structure I think in certain types
of openings we see nihal play a lot
faster than usual and that bodes really
well for his chances in the end game
that night on D2 I'm also looking at
that Knight and I'm saying well what's
the ideal place for that night and it's
probably the B5 square there's a juicy
Outpost that's calling White's name so
Knight B1 Knight A3 Knight B5 is also an
idea to explore if you're knee-haul of
course if you play Knight B1 then the
Knight on G5 can also jump into its own
outpost on e4
yeah no love that idea right there so
maybe it might be one right here he goes
H4 kicking the Knight back it has to go
to H7 and now he's gaining space on the
king side and he's not attacking I think
newer players might think that White's
attacking on the king side no the idea
is as you said to gain space control
important squares but this could also
backfire you could bite off more than
you can chew if you're not careful now
you have to decide whether you're
playing G5 and he does
G5 looks like a nice move and Diane just
actually could turn into an attack let's
say you go 98. maybe white just takes
place Rook G1 followed by H5 if you
trade on G5 why you can easily take
advantage of the HR with Rook H1 Bishop
5 to follow and is he gonna go for it
here
I love that this idea is positional and
tactical at the same time he's garnering
squares for his pieces you know Knight
F3 now he's got the clamp on the dark
squares in the center but after
something like Knight E5 you're right
Benjamin this could absolutely turn into
a mating attack down the h-file in the
long run now I feel like the trend of
the game is once again in White's favor
yeah it looks great here for a nihal MPL
does not have a single Palm brick B5 is
not available you can take on D4 but why
it just recaptures with the e-pawn and I
I really like this idea of Knight E5 and
after a trade you were captured with the
Knight then you go Knight to G4 you clam
down on any F6 F5 pushes you move your
Rook to H1 you move your part of
the way and then after 96 take Stakes
you double the Rooks and it's just gonna
be Checkmate along the H file normally
these types of long plans are
unrealistic because the opponent will
respond with an active idea of their own
and you will have to respond to that but
because of your point the black lacks
Pawn breaks you actually can plan for
the future right you can plan for the
time that you're 60 and can you know
finally pull money out of your IRA this
is only a couple of moves away right 95
that's one move Knight G4 Rook H1 we're
only talking about three or four moves
and black will be then staring down the
barrel of a really nasty attack down the
H file
e5k and we see the trade and I guess
he's his Knight is headed to G4
indeed what does MBL do if he takes on
E5 he merely exacerbates those glaring
dark Square weaknesses on the king side
I think that this can we say that it's
almost borderline lost here for black
I mean it's still a little bit early to
call this loss but it looks extremely
problematic I think white has got real
chances here of launching a deadly
attack along the H file
absolutely now unveiled down under a
minute
I'm at a loss
for moves here Rook A7 okay he's gearing
up for potentially a king run I mean he
might have to evacuate his King via f8
and E8 and maybe he was trying to
prevent Knight D7 check which would Fork
the king in the B6 Pawn I think we're
gonna see King f8 and King E7 and I
think that might be Black's best
practical chance seeking shelter in the
center but white could still infiltrate
down the H file even with the black king
absent from the King side
exactly I think black has to get that
King out of there as quickly as possible
if nihal goes Knight G4 maybe then also
you go Bishop D6 and the King can no
longer run and then Knight F6 that pawn
and F6 will completely freeze the king
over here and then you double the Rooks
so mvl he's down to 20 seconds and I
think like I said he just has to run and
there he goes and I think we will see
Knight G4 by nihal clamping down on
those dark squares E5 and F6 and white
doesn't even have to play Bishop H2 to
E5 white can just tip the bishop over to
G3 and that might be even better because
the G7 Bishop is actually a Target you
might not want to trade that Bishop you
might want to attack it with your Rook
instead
exactly and I think that's much better
because where does the bishop go you can
go to f8 oh that looks extremely passive
nehal and said goes Bishop before Diana
so far this has been a Master Class by
nihal two position incredible positional
games and this one is not complete yet
he needs to finish this off with a
couple accurate moves don't forget about
the queen side you know that B6 spawn it
could be attacked in some cases with a
bishop from C7 and nehal is really
really good at using both sides of the
board these are professional attacks
right oftentimes you have to exploit
weaknesses everywhere and he plays it
Bishop C7 Rook takes G7 and Rook h8
apparently is a winning idea but that's
unfindable or is it
that is a very nice
and Rook EA Checkmate what do you do you
can go King D7 though but you move to
Bishop anyway Knight of six is
Unstoppable you could also get your H1
Rook to F3 I think we might see Rook H3
Rook F3 and then Knight F6 oh he's fine
he goes for it he's found it
Rook A8 Bishop takes B6 it's still
losing positionally you're busted
on C5 threatening mates so nice to go
King D6 to C7 five seconds for mvl the
threat is Bishop C5 and Rook a chain
he's just resigned this is a epic epic
positional win by nihal
it was a great game by nehal and you
know I say all of these memes about the
London now the London players are
laughing back here they're like okay you
look at the wind there was a great one
by Nihon I think Lost in You know the
the details of those trolley battles is
the fact that the London actually is a
great opening it's a dangerous opening
nobody really likes to play against it
and nihal is a specialist in that
opening it's two to one
mess up the opening here because I think
after C4 now you don't have a good
response normally you or is it still
fine after 90 seconds is this still the
theory man I I don't play this for
either caller I definitely don't play
the pet shop for black with white I've
mostly relied on Sidelines and I think
we're gonna see Knight C3 here and the
hanging Pawn structure which feels
pretty good for white because that Queen
on D5 is is not safe it's not a good
block hater because it can be so easily
pushed away uh by either a minor piece
or a pawn from C4
right 96 is super important move as now
in case why take some rookie one the
bishop on E7 is defended so let's see
what MPL is going to do he goes rookie
one now I I expect Bishop to F5 and then
after Knight C3 we will probably see
some trades and it's important to
indicate that after Bishop F5 if white
takes on e4 and plays Knight C3 that
looks like it wins a minor piece but
black has the move Bishop takes F3
counter-attacking White's Queen so the
tactics work out in Black's favor here
which is why white generally plays
Knight C3 and orchestrates these minor
piece trades
right because I think that's all those
traits that just leads to an equal end
game so probably mvl is going to play
this move you can also develop your
Bishop let's say that four to Target
this Pawn but I think we're still in in
petrol Theory as if I'm not mistaken but
hey I also don't play the patch off
although maybe mvl doesn't play this
line either because he's the one taking
large chunks of time here maybe he is
skeptical about nehal's opening setup
but it it doesn't look like there's
anything direct here I think you have to
go Knight C3 and it feels like white is
slightly better in that resulting
position what is MV looking for here
it's a good question I think overall
knee-hel can be quite satisfied with the
way the match is going he's been putting
pressure in these knee-haul type
positions with white and with black yes
he lost the first game but he had a fine
position out of the opening and here he
seems to be doing fine as well Bishop F4
so he delays the development of his
Knight to see three and instead gets his
Bishop out hits C7
and Knight takes D4 I'm too lazy to
consider that move no it doesn't work
because if Bishop takes E4
right yeah you cannot take over there
also in case of a move like Rook seed
maybe then you can take any foreplay
Knight C3 and if we go down that line
once again it might be a little bit
better for writers that's horrific C7
this Pawn is hanging your Bishop D1 is
hanging as well so white should win at
least upon there
maybe we can make those moves on the
board really quickly and pull up an
analysis board I think that's a very
instructive line
um just to help players visualize that
end game Knight C3 Bishop F3 everything
is captured and it's so important
Benjamin I think you'll second me on
this too the one of the hardest aspects
of Chess is to evaluate positions at the
end of a long line because they're kind
of blurry in your mind but this is
clearly a one-sided end game even if it
is a draw objectively
[Music]
right instead we see the move Bishop B4
by Neil by the way fun fact we're gonna
say it turns out to be just a losing
move after Queen B3 as the queen is
saying and you're just losing the night
of Bishop before Oh much better by nihal
okay rookie three we've got a very messy
position all of a sudden
the Knight on e4 right that is the
centerpiece that is the chief factor is
that Knight a strength or is it going to
be targeted by White's Queen can white
take on C7 here I mean lots of questions
you can but I guess black just goes Rook
to D7 attacking the bishop and after
Bishop moose then you take on D4 and
dying I love what nihal is doing all of
his pieces are in the game and MPL still
has not developed this enemy one now it
no longer can and also this Rook is
still stuck on A1 I don't understand why
Maxine procrastinated with the move
Knight C3 and he procrastinated so much
that now he can't play that move at all
and he's got a hard time completing his
Queen side development now the D4 Pawn
was Untouchable earlier but it's not
going to be Untouchable forever it is a
weakness it is an isolated pawn and I
think nihal can calmly drop his Knight
back to F6 and he's gonna be better
because mvl has awkward piece
coordination and he's got this long-term
weakness on D4
yeah I like that of six just addressing
the threat on the Knight this trade is
pretty fine for black opponent D4 is
still hanging so looks pretty good for
nehal I mean he also I mean I don't
think all of these lines work so like I
said I think it just has to draw back
the night this may seem irrelevant but
in the event that white takes on C7 LAX
response could actually be Rook d8 to C8
because there is a back rank weakness as
long as white doesn't develop his Knight
there's a back rank weakness that could
be exploited instead nihal goes very
direct speaking of back rank weakness
whoa is there Queen takes B2 here oh my
gosh is there Queen takes B2
if there is if you take any four quintix
B2 looks cool
they're from Roti one so what do you
even do here with white Enfield 93 only
move you have to get the night out and
guard your background but after Bishop
C6 the smoke finally clears and it looks
like black is somewhat better
black is definitely better but I think
if you're MPL you're happy that you're
not lost right because it easily could
have been right if Queen takes B2 would
have landed why did she was getting
crushed but here after Bishop C6 yes
black is better because the bishop pair
but white is still very much in the game
I think nihal is trying to assess Bishop
takes G2 which is a discovered attack on
the bishop but there is Bishop E5 there
and the queen can't land on a square
where it guards the bishop on G2 because
D5 G4 and E4 obviously are all under
White's defense so I think Neil just has
to satisfy himself with a bishop pair
and better piece activity in that open
Center position
right you can also go Bishop D3
attacking the queen so that after Queen
after queen move so you can then address
the threat on the pawn the problem
however is that azer Bishop D3 why
because queen of three also taking this
one over here and they bring the idea of
rookie one into the position great Point
nihal taking a long time here he's down
below 90 seconds but I think he feels
that this position is relatively easy to
play and there isn't a lot of risk for
black it's not easy to make a blunder
and we know how comfortable nihal is
even in Middle games when he's got a
couple seconds on the clock
right he has to be careful though he's
dropping down to a minute but I think
after Bishop C6 he's doing absolutely
fine he's probably just better white
probably has to take the spawn over here
could mvl also I mean Bishop B5 and Rook
G3 I don't think is that effective as
black always has to move F6 I think
that's a paper tiger and I think I'd be
all makes the correct decision now
another decision for black where does he
go Rook D7 or Rook E8 I like rookie that
disarms White's Rook on E3 that's the
same Rook which could have later slid
over to G3 and attacked G7 so a
comfortable comfortable position here
for knee-hal we might get a bunch of
Trades down the e-file we might get an
end game here
um and I think mvl has to position okay
Bishop E5 keeping the pieces on the
board
right now Neil asked him was Queen I
like to move Queen H4 maybe Queen G5
potentially threatening Checkmate on G2
you could also move the queen to like C5
or D7 but yeah and he goes for 27 I
guess he wants to reposition his Queen
on the F5 Square
good move Queen F5 is what we will see
the queen aims at the bishop preventing
the white Rook from moving out of the E
file importantly the bishop on C6 guards
The Rook on E8 there are no Shenanigans
with Bishop takes G7 none of that will
work because the Rook on E8 is safely
protected moreover that Rook on E8 uh
you know two can play at The Rook lift
game it can move up to E6 and later to
G6 and you can also double on the eighth
ring on the e-file and exert pressure on
White's Bishop on E5
right and another unpleasant idea here
would be to move Bishop to C5 hitting
the rook in E3 The Rock and the move as
I would leave the bishop on E5 hanging I
suppose you still have to move Bishop to
D4 but everything starts to become a
little bit loose for white and that's
why we see mvl also spending some time
here maybe he should just play Move Like
H3 create some low for his King and pass
and move the knee-hal yeah sometimes
when you can't figure out what to do the
answer is that you essentially should do
nothing right you should make a healthy
waiting move and that's exactly what he
does a very mature decision by mvl not
doing anything drastic tossing the ball
back into nihal's court and given that
Neal has 30 seconds it's a pretty
effective strategy now 28 seconds for
nihal sarin we're gonna see another one
of those vintage knee-haul time
scrambles
right and even though he's better here
to position I mean it could potentially
still flip around there's still a lot of
pieces on the board mpl's gonna deny
they can be tricky in time scrambles I
think that he's taking a little bit too
much time 10 seconds for Niha he is like
glutton for punishment he's gonna play
the rest of this game in single digit
time this is crazy he's got rookie six
he's going after mvl's King threatening
Rook G6 but Rook G6 Benjamin is not a
horrible threat I think white can block
either with his Rook or with his Bishop
although that Bishop C5 idea could
potentially end up being nasty Rook G6
here looks pretty good
yeah Rook G6 looks good wait he takes on
C3 that's a pretty bailout decision
now mvl can just recapture and he's
absolutely Thunder I love the move Rook
G6 there is how do you defend now you
can go Rook G3 but blackened taking you
have to weaken your Pawn structure yeah
I think if nihal had maybe 10 more
seconds he would have gone for the
immediate Rook G6 he's trying to
minimize his risk mitigate his risk
because with opposite colored Bishops
anytime black trades Queens I think
we're gonna head in the direction of a
draw Queen F2 I think that's where we're
going
yeah queen of two he's probably gonna
trade you can also keep the Queens on
the board and maybe then just rookie one
he goes crazy five okay rookie two can
uh but then there's 48 so MPL could just
take the Palm he should take the pawn
and he does take the pawn and Niha has
to make some Luft and he does and even
upon down I think black isn't really
risking here Benjamin because White's
pawns are disjointed on the queen side
and they're never gonna amount to
anything even in a middle game
exactly Quincy four it's even difficult
to see how you hang on to the spawn but
for the moment mvl is keeping his extra
Pawn on the board Rook A8 I mean
rookie rookie one rookie we might get a
repetition exactly in that way two
seconds for Newhall and it's MV all who
goes for it but I don't see nihal losing
this game he's got no weaknesses
but he's got no time so I think
absolutely correct decision by mvl to
play on here King H2 and at the rimo
maybe Rook at 4 to G4
okay Rook F4 Queen E2 had to be assessed
he goes Queen F4 and undoubles his pawns
now it's mvl who's technically the one
pressing but it still looks like a dead
draw to me Black's pieces are
sufficiently active here in that Bishop
on C6 Will Survive a nuclear apocalypse
oh careful careful now if you're mvl
don't get me get yourself mated
I like what he's doing though he's
pushing this apron on the board in case
black would have taken it would hang the
B7 Pawn I don't see a way to get uh
Checkmate those Bishop to G2 is
currently unavailable and suddenly
there's a threat of White's Rook
infiltrating the sixth rank he's trying
to get his Rook to B6 and nihal has to
avoid Bishop C6 because A6 undermines
the bishop this is getting a little bit
scary mvl doing a great job of
generating chance it's gonna fly and he
Flex he flagged
what a game
that was incredible yeah it's it's a
tough position and we've talked about
this before it's incredible how usually
he doesn't blunder he doesn't fly but
sometimes he does it's it's very easy
with only one second of incurrent and
Benjamin this wasn't a flashy conversion
by mvl but the fact that he generated
chances in that opposite card Bishop
position which originally was a dead
draw was incredible nihal overpressed he
should have swapped Queens when he had a
chance and he's going to be punished if
he always gets himself to single digit
time in a middle game that's how good
mvl is anyways the score after four
games is all tied up at two a piece as
we enter our midpoint break of the five
plus one segment Benjamin I don't think
anybody is surprised that we've got a
tide match
yeah I'm not surprised with the fact
that the match is tied so let's see what
happens in the other uh half of this
portion and we will be back with more
SCC action presented by coinbase on the
other side of this short break
[Music]
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
started by focusing on classical chess
but later we fell in love with playing
Blitz and bullet online
chess has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SCC
happen go to coinbase.com update the
system to learn more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battle heart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the ultra Queen thinks highly of herself
and for good reason she is a skilled
tactician deadly opponent and your worst
nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back or shall I say welcome back
to the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase there is the
Frenchman with three names as he shovels
down a couple of pre-game snacks we are
halfway through the five minute portion
of the match between the hulsar and mvl
the score all tied at two a piece white
has won four games black has won zero
it's been a very high level match close
match everything that we've expected
that we've asked for we have gotten
Benjamin buck
yeah I know for sure nihal took the lead
in the match but MPL he won a position
that seemed completely unwinnable he
went up upon hang on to it and in
nihal's time trouble he created
practical problems that led to nihal
losing on time
yeah that was a frustrating game for
nihal because he was in the driver's
seat his Petrov against mvl's one E4 has
been going pretty well he's gotten the
positions that he wants out of the
opening so I don't think we're going to
see any drastic adjustments on nihal
side on mvl side it was concerning the
kind of position that he's been getting
out of nihal's London system he might
want to make some changes
yeah for sure I think he used the brake
to check that London system real quick
check what he had to do there
differently I think he played pretty
well for the most part but I think
usually black should go for a quick like
f60 E5 there uh and also he might want
to switch up his one E4 like what he's
doing with why because he didn't really
get anything from his white games
and there we see nihal the expert in the
jabala London he is so dangerous with
the white pieces he seems to be in
pretty good spirits talking to someone
there off a camera his SCC record is
Stellar he's defeated so many top
players uh in his
previous years SCC appearances he has
won the jscc dangly Iran Anish giri
Richard report Alexander grishek are
among his victims he's so impressive
Benjamin and the fact that he's under
2700 doesn't fool anybody he can
absolutely go very very high in the SEC
but anyways our next game is underway
this is game five the score is two to
two and we've got another 43 minutes of
five plus one to play they are reprising
the opening from the first game
yeah I think nihal did get a slight edge
here E3 he's gonna follow with H3 to
give this bishop a little bit of lift on
H2 and also of course his King I wonder
what exactly MPL is going to do
differently maybe MPL did not mind this
position as much but he did not like the
position he got in the inner grundfault
worldwide went for the job of London
setup yeah no question that this was a
better relative position to to the third
game but at the same time it still felt
like nehal had had gained a slight Edge
out of the opening this time MBL issues
the early B7 B5 that we saw and develops
his Knight to A6 probably that is merely
a Transit point for the Knight because
it has no future on A6 especially after
nihal's last move
right and I like that nihal has played
the move Rook to C1 as now black can no
longer go B5 as there will always be
Knight takes B5 instead MPL goes rookie
but I think after push me too and the
queen side castles white is having a
very slight Edge agreed and what
exacerbates the situation for black is
is the placement of the queen on C8 you
would want to park that Queen you know
D7 C7 but neither of those squares are
accessible c7s controlled and if you
play Queen D7 you run right into Knight
F3 to E5 so mvl just kind of trying to
contort himself maybe get some pieces
off the board make this easier to play I
think he's just one or two beautiful
tactic and he sees it instantly
and exactly take here and you take a D5
and the queen is hanging at the end and
yeah what do you do I mean there is
Bishop before the end but then even
Queen H5 and you defend the knights to
make sure everyone has to double your
pawns how quickly did nihal and not only
did he find it quickly he had the
confidence to execute the moves within a
couple of seconds he's one upon let's
not overstate the case the game isn't
over in fact Queen H5 is a very
important resource otherwise black would
take on F3
draw
wow and mvl with a right smile he sees
it
for sure yeah it's it's almost like the
tactic that he initially blundered right
with Bish takes E6 and then the whole
sequence of Knight takes D5 and here he
can oh he goes rookie six do you think
he missed it all together or he just
didn't like it after let's say rookie
won I was gonna actually say maybe he's
I know it sounds crazy but black might
be playing for a win here White's King
is really really weak a move like Queen
D7 here sets up really nasty threats
against the H3 Pawn I'm very bemused at
nihal's decision to allow Bishop takes
F3 when he had the move Queen H5 in his
pocket I feel like he's regretting that
decision Rook takes E3 the fact remains
was a really beautiful drawing tactic
yeah I'm surprised that mvl missed that
after Queen E7 he still has pretty
reasonable compensation like I said I'm
shocked that nihal did not play Queen H5
defending the knight in F3 and that
looked like a very clean extra Pawn now
he has to go like King H2 mid Rook Hicks
with F5 it's still holding together but
MPL can also try to bring this other
Rook into the action rookie Aid rookie 8
rookie four it takes a long time but in
the meantime what exactly is y gonna do
yeah I think that's the X Factor can
black get that other Rook you know out
of A6 and toward the center toward the
king side New Hall going for the pass
that you prescribed mvl induced the move
F5 and now goes back to the center
threatening Rook D5 which would pick off
the F5 Pawn
what is Neil's response to this threat
right before but look at this queen E5
now in case rookie five there's Queen B8
and you force the trade of Queen so mvl
goes rotate but now there's time for a
rookie one threatening Checkmate over
here and nihal has nicely positioned his
pieces on the queen side on the king
side you can also consider dropping your
queen along this diagonal to F4 or even
G3 aiming at The Rook aiming at the G7
pawn and you know really clinging to
that F5 Pawn with your teeth
still feels like nehals in the driver's
seat a lot depends on you know the
future of this F5 Pawn can nehal keep it
using tactical methods or will MBL
eventually win it back and restore
material equality
yeah perhaps at some point Niha will
have to bank on move Rook to C5 and go
for that trade to make sure he doesn't
hang this Pawn
um however the pollen C5 becomes a
little bit vulnerable Blake then also
gets the open default for their Queen to
create counter players most likely to D2
so let's see what nihal is going to do
who again drops down on the clock
big moment here Rook G1 Queen G3 you
could play the immediate Rook C5
and try to preempt Rook D5 of course
that would run into B6 but then the C6
Pawn is weakened so there's a lot to
consider here if you're Neil and he's
been doing this throughout the match he
he's not afraid to take well over a
minute on a single move they're going
down exactly the path that you laid out
Rook C5 there's a trade and now mvl is
heading for E5 an excellent Square for
his Rook
rookie five which would form the pawns
on F5 and C5 it's not easy to see how
you hang on to those line you can play
B4 let's say defend upon a C5 and S35 go
E4 but then black gets moves like Queen
of D4 and opponent B4 is very vulnerable
in the meantime it's difficult for you
to create real threats on the king side
in a way this is reminding me of the
previous game where new Hall's been in
the driver's seat since the opening
since he found that beautiful tactic but
then he lets him his clock run down and
sometimes he he has the capacity to over
press and try a little bit too hard
let's see if you can play more
objectively here and keep more time on
his clock B4 is on the board so he
secures the C5 Pawn but after rookie
five he'll have another big decision to
make will oh A4 never mind
I'm surprised by that decision by MPL I
thought he should have traded on before
and that before would have always been a
witness but instead he's banging on the
A3 Pawn but it's always going to take
such a long time together you're gonna
have to go Queen D3 take the pawn and in
the meantime Vice for sure will have
some of the threats cooked up on the
king side
definitely now Queen G3 is is in nihal's
Pocket as a way to aim at the G7 Pawn
he's got to decide whether he plays E4
in this position and my instinct would
be to play E4 but then you are giving up
the D4 square and once the queen lands
on D4 it's also pressuring the F2 Pawn
so that's a pretty unpleasant thing to
allow maybe E4 Queen D3 is also on the
horizon for ambo but then Queen C7 so a
lot to calculate here
yeah I think you always want to play a
move like rookie five first to shut the
queen out from coming to C7 or B8 and
then go for stuff like Queen E3 but now
nihal's got time so let's see what he
can do he goes Rook G4 so after rookie
five maybe he's well what do you think
he's planning
well he's got two pieces now both of his
pieces on the fourth rank so maybe he
wants to shuttle his Queen over to D4
and he wants to say listen I'm gonna
give up the F5 Pawn but then you're
gonna have to give me Superior Rook
placement in the end game that's a very
high level idea by nihal and I think
it's a great way uh to keep the heat on
mvl
yeah trading looks very risky for black
if I can just recapture and after
because Rook takes F5 I think you just
play F4 and the 4.5 is completely stuck
and in the meantime white is going to
pick up these pawns on the queen side
and Rook D5 for sure is not available as
you just trade and play B5 and C6 and
then B6 at the end is a very important
breakthrough black is one tempo away
from stopping the pawn
and VL has to calculate that which means
he's out of options Rook D5 here would
be a great move except it runs into
Queen takes F6 that detail had to be
foreseen by nihal when he was playing
Rook G4
and after Rook takes a five there
there's Rook takes G7 can mvl just take
the pawn on F5 or is there a check king
of seven and queen C7 maybe rookie seven
you take on G7 we go down the screen and
game is is this winning Donya
it's hard to say and I would be very
scared of going for this if I'm mvl he
takes a different approach the queen
moves away to C7 and now he's gonna take
on F5 and now there is no back rank
check maybe nihal rushed his response
King G2 it did seem forced but the
engine was indicating another
possibility Queen to D1 though niho
eyeing that A4 Pawn but does he have
time to take it with his King as weak as
it is
I don't think so now his work is under
attack I guess he has to go Rook D4 or
Rook G3 quite a big decision to make
here if you go Rook before there will
always be an unpleasant check on G5 he
goes back to G3
okay now the pawn A4 cannot be directly
defended because after B5 there is
unpeasant C takes B6 so mvl has to
abandon that pawn and queen F7 is such a
high class move aiming for D5 Queen D5
check will cause further weaknesses in
White's position I think nehal should
not touch that pawn and A4
no for sure I think the public is
extremely risky there's going to be
Queen D5 maybe followed by Queen E2 and
upon that two will be extremely
uncomfortable to defend and Daya we
talked about this earlier how wide could
sa a queen trade on the default maybe
black can do that here with Queen E5 as
the rook and G3 is kind of out of the
game and it's exactly the same problem
that faced black except now it faces
white the A3 Pawn which mvl fixed all
those moves ago with the move A4 that
could actually come in handy which is
why I think nihal refrains from allowing
the queen trade he plays the movie E4
and now Rook F4 or rookie 5. rookie five
he goes for rookie five hitting the pawn
queen D4 but the quality for somewhat
weak maybe just Queen E7 or queen E6 is
possible but it allows us to check on d8
I don't know if you want to do that he
goes King H7 instead and die and we've
talked about this before Neil had a
slight Edge he was up upon but MPL right
now is certainly in a driver's seat
especially if you look at the clock
absolutely 12 seconds for anyhow lots of
Pawns that he's got to defend he goes
rookie three I think that is a good spot
a good defensive spot for his Rook he's
defending both H3 and E4 and he's got
something resembling I don't want to say
a fortress but a good solid defensive
construction Queen back to D1 attacking
A4 and VL storm cloud starting to gather
around White's King this is getting
really really practically unpleasant for
white five seconds for nihal can he hold
this together E5
right he goes E5 and maybe like Rook F5
taking a Pawn on F2 and it's quite
uncomfortable to defend upon the pawn
and E5 can also always be taken although
I think if you think right now there's
Queen D3 and Nihao might be able to
escape with a Perpetual that is nihal's
idea Queen D3 check and he will hunt
after Black's King I don't think that
mvl can escape the Perpetual he's
certainly trying though King H6 and
queen D6 check Rook G6 and you might get
checkmated
this has to be when Queen C2 and they
use zigzag 2D and take H3 H3 oh my gosh
what a beautiful wind Queen C2 and you
can't go to E1 because of Rook G1 mate
it's gonna it's a lost all right
wow
my gosh King F1 was also losing but it
would have taken a little bit more
Precision from mvl and he wins the first
victory for either side of the black
pieces and the Frenchman with three
names leads this match by one
what a turnaround dying we saw Nihao
winning that pawn in the middle game and
it seemed that he just had a risk-free
position but MPL combined the pressure
on Niels King and on the clock and he
managed to win the one and we're just so
used to complete Excellence from nihal
with a couple of seconds that you know
we almost take it for granted that he's
gonna get a position with five seconds
to his opponent's minute and be fine but
mvl's one of those guys that you can't
do that against reliably right you're
going to drop some games if you keep
doing that to yourself with Queens on
the board and with the position tactical
nihal is a wizard but there's only so
much that even a wizard can do with
three seconds to calculate crazy lines
yeah no we saw in the first game that he
managed to convert his Advantage into
win but overall Diane I think he really
has to play a little bit faster we saw
also in game four how he managed to lose
a position that seemed risk-free so I
think as long as there is some risk in
the position MPL can really turn
anything around when Neil gets along
time and we have our first opening
change of the match this started out as
a Karo Khan an advanced variation and
now we have a structure that resembles I
don't know a French Bishop takes H6 by
the way yeah you gotta consider it
right and then both Knights can jump
into the actual 95 and Knight G5 and
vl's looking at us for sure
the wheels are turning in his brain
right now Bishop takes H6 GH Queen G6 a
tactic that's similar in some way to
that Rook take C3 uh tactic that he
didn't end up playing in the previous
game and ended up getting rewarded for
that because he ultimately won the game
now Bishop takes H6 is not forced you
can also Play Bishop H4 obviously black
then cannot play G5 because of that same
check on G6
right yeah I like the move Bishop you
can combine it with a move like Knight
H5 putting some pressure on the Knight
maybe Queen G6 potentially but I'm sure
mvl's looking at this so let's have a
look so it takes takes you give a check
the king steps over you take over here
Knight H7 maybe then like not H5 or do
you take over here what exactly is going
through his mind right now that I am
well he's he's weighing the options
Bishop takes H6 if it works could lead
to a quick Victory but I don't think
it's the kind of sacrifice that has the
capacity to to win in like five moves
because black can hide on h8 with his
King and then cover it with Knight F6 to
H7 I agree with mvl's decision I think
Bishop H4 keeps all the assets in his
position and if you think about this
strategically Benjamin he's got that E5
Square under lock and key which is why I
like the move Knight H5 if you trade a
pair of knights on F6 you increase your
control over the E5 Square
exactly will be much more difficult to
ever get that E5 push in he can then
double up the Rooks on the e-file black
and black the evil for the moment with
94 but white can always move that Knight
out of the way go 92 trade Nihon Celtics
with the g-pawn wow
he takes with a Jeep on and I think
that's precisely why he wants to guard
the E5 square but he's traded one
ailment for another now his King is very
very weak his Pawn structure is flimsy
and it feels like positionally he's in a
lot of trouble here
yeah I like this for MPL you can trade
on G3 and then play E5 but that's going
to weaken the F5 score why canango
Knight H4 to F5 threaten all sorts of
forks in case of E4 the queen can always
slide back to D2 put some more pressure
already here look who can slide into F4
so like you said he's traded off one
weakness for another
and he's probably contemplating the move
E5 which looks fancy it looks like a
nice move but it weakens the F5 square
and the queen can sink its teeth into
that square and then the knight from F3
can dive into H4 this is yucky this is a
yucky position for black
I don't like it at all white is a very
easy play here also just rookie two
followed by Rook 81 Putting suppression
upon an E6 so the position really plays
itself here for mvl
I think it's an instructive position for
newer players who might think that after
E5 black controls more of the center and
so Black's got to be fine but that
doesn't tell the whole story just
because you have pawns on D5 and E5
doesn't mean anything White's got
massive pressure on that Center and
there are so many squares that you're
weakening with that move he plays E5
trying to generate active counter play
in the center but Queen F5 is going to
put a serious damper on that
or Knight H4 I love to move yeah I love
both those moves in that Detroit F5
looks great and that's what mvl goes for
there's no good way for nihal to stop it
you can again go E4 but it's gonna
weaken even more squares so I don't know
that it looks tough for black
yeah E4 any move you make with a pawn is
just gonna create more weaknesses like
E4 opens up some dark squares and the
queen can drop back to D2 let's not
forget about the H6 Pawn which is
isolated and it is eminently attackable
by White's Queen and Knight
right so maybe you have to play a move
like Queen to H7 to try to get the
Queen's off he goes Bishop D6 instead is
that he used to be Knight of five with
bishta fate and add to bring the bishop
to the defense but maybe at some point
Diane mvl could go for like rookie three
and bring the Rook over to the H or G
file
absolutely Rook E3 Rook ae1 is a great
multi-purpose idea setting up the Rook
lift and increasing the pressure on E5 I
would play it right now rookie three no
drawbacks to that move
right perhaps what nihal has to do with
Rook E3 is trade on D4 trade of the
Rooks to make sure that Rook never joins
the attack however you give white the
open F all to work with you can go
Bishop 4 guard upon Rook F1 to F3 the G3
and if the King was over there's Knight
G6 so this could lead to a deadly attack
for MBL
ack has zero active prospects here any
muscle that he moves is just gonna
create more prospects for White's pieces
I think it's worth mentioning that the
top engine move here is A5 which really
tells you all that you need to know
about Black's position okay nehal makes
a much more human move he trades on D4
trading off a couple of pieces trying to
make it easier for himself to defend
this but Bishop F4 just keeps all of
White's advantages intact
yeah Bishop before defends everything in
defense upon E3 Queen F3 also possible
he now clears the F5 Square for his
Knight but I really like the queen there
because he could then easily lift The
Rook up with Rook of one to F3 now B3 A
very wise move stopping the knight from
jumping into C4 and the Knight jumps
back to C8 he is playing great boa
constrictor chess Anvil showing that
he's not just a one-trick pony he's not
just a tactician and queen is gonna dive
into H5 and this is exactly what I talk
about any move that black makes opens up
new squares for White's pieces look at
the way that he has paralyzed Black's
forces the Knight on C8 it can't move to
E7 it can't move to D6 The Rook is under
Fire the pawn on H6 is under Fire and
the Queen on E6 is just helplessly
staring down the barrel of a
well-defended Pawn on E3 black is
essentially out of moves here
right and what do you do here white is
starting to go bishop and Bishop takes a
chick so Rook d8 good move clearing of
the E8 score for his Queen Bishop f4 on
the board Queen E8 only moving the queen
is gonna drop back to H3 and at that
point you're gonna have to start looking
for tactics with a bishop sack on H6
that Rook lifts Benjamin that you talked
about Rook F3 I think now's a great time
for Rook F3 and then you will be
threatening Bishop takes H6 and Rook G3
you can actually play Bishop takes H6
now and then play Rook F3
wow that's quite a nice continuation I
want to have Rook of three right now can
be met with Knight E7 or is there a
tactic for white
there's gotta be and White's gonna have
to find something there because if you
trade off Knights then finally the kind
of embargo starts getting lifted on
Black's pieces there's a check on B1
that you have to watch out for in the in
the event of a rook lift so there's
there's still work left to be done here
and we've seen the hall save uh you know
crazy lost positions so many times MBL
knows that and that's why he's investing
a good chunk of time here
right so let's see what he's going to do
there's always going to be sacrifice
over here because 94 instead okay as it
is that to meet Queen E4 with Knight F5
and the queen all of a sudden is
completely shot out of the defense
however what is he planning to do in the
event of Queen 2 H5
I think that is the question nihal has
to ask is there some sort of Bishop C7
Queen D7 check trick here wow again
using the whole board uh as a canvas
Bishop C7 I think is the cleanest
winning move it might be the only move
that wins cleanly
right so let's have a look so Bishop C7
rookie 8 is forced Queen do you have a
check over here and then like maybe 97.
even rookie 7 has to be considered there
then you take on C8 you take an H4 he's
got it he's found it Queen D7 check
about to appear on The Rook F6 just
grabbing a pawn
there's your G7 though kicking The Rook
away and there is always a potential
Queen you uncheck on the queen D1 check
right now will be met with Rook F1
Bishop E7 also possible
right I would try Bishop
and hitting the Knight as well
I think it's a good practical try
obviously white is winning we're not
disputing debating that how do you
create the most practical chances since
NBL is under a minute here that's the
big question for nihal
right let's see how he will do it Bishop
G7 also brings ideas of a potential Rook
text E3 and Bishop 64. it doesn't work
for the moment but that idea it it
enters the position and that's what you
got to do you got to set up these
potential tricks so that when the
situation descends into a Time scramble
you've got a an assemblage of these
potential tactics that are easy to miss
30 seconds now for any Hall hoping
against hope to find some way to
complicate The Narrative I stand by what
I think Bishop E7 is the best try here
maybe white even has G4 in response to
that and mvl is spending this time
wisely he's calculating he's just gotten
an additional 30 seconds to figure out
his responses to these moves Bishop G7
is nihal's choice
all right so the Rook is on our attack
so we're just going to go Rook at 5 is
an option but then black can jump in we
need two or queen E2 and how do you find
the part of e3 oh my gosh Queen E2 and
the game is starting to turn around
you're right Benjamin Rook F3 Queen E1
check
okay now he trades Bishops
and suddenly you take oh my look at this
guy you can take on E5 twice but it goes
97. you can
yes because if you would have taken the
version Queen you won mate
Oh I thought Whitehead Queen F1 but no
holy smokes we have to show this after
the game because nihal has just missed a
huge opportunity and mvl is winning once
more Rook F7
Queen D1 Rook F1
it just slides The Rook back maybe now
you just trade and go Queen E6 that
looks absolutely crushing
totally but black just is out of ideas
Bishop white is Apple Pawn that's not
like you've sacrificed something Queen
E5 oh well this is mate because Queen E6
comes with a check check checkmate I
mean you just you just let your hand
make the moves here Queen takes H6 as
possible Knight G6 and he's resigned
oh wow what a game a pretty dominant
performance by MPL but just for a moment
they're dying he led nihal back into the
game absolutely maybe in our next break
uh before the three minute segment
starts we could show that Rook takes C5
trick that was a beautiful deflection
but nihal again he was down to five
seconds imagine you cannot blame him for
missing one individual specific tactic
that would have brought him back to the
game it's amazing that he created those
chances to begin with but the fact
remains he is down down two points and
this is exactly what mvl wants right a
two or three point cushion going into
the next segment
right and here we have another London
system yeah you can criticize him for
missing those Moves In A Time scramble
but you can criticize him for getting
that low on time I mean there are no
heroes in times in time scrambles like
everyone their players who are better
but everyone makes mistakes well said no
matter how practiced you are how good of
a bullet or hyper bullet player you are
when you're facing a top Grand Master
they're always going to find ways to
post problems in any position
practically in time pressure so
tough going here tough sledding uh for
nehal after a great start his one point
lead has been erased and reversed okay
what do we have here we have another one
of those slav grunfeldy positions H5 by
mvl trying to restrict white activity on
the king side not as drastic of a move
as it may appear to a newer player
because the queen trade is so likely and
it's not like black is creating major
weaknesses on his King side
right I'm still slightly surprised by
this move I wonder if G4 was really a
concern just yet uh nihal just continues
his development with Bishop to E2 the
problem dying with this bishop 105 is
that at some point you might want to
play the move E6 to strength in your
Center but then the bishop really has
nowhere to go to and if white moves this
Knight out of the way it could
potentially get trapped we see a queen
trade who benefits in your opinion
I think white wider captures towards the
center defenses C4 Pawn a little bit
more and also opens up the a fall for
their Rook now we see King side Castle I
think white would love to go let's say
Rook fc1 maybe B4 and 92 to B3 to A5 to
put some pressure on opponent B7
I agree I think nihal is is very happy
to re this is also very much in his
style he he is a positional player at
heart he likes the I mean who doesn't
like a slightly better end game right
but what I mean is he's really really
good most of the time at converting
these types of end games and he tends to
play faster in positions that he's
comfortable with I think this is exactly
one of those types of positions where we
might see a different nihal Saran than
we saw in the previous couple games
and I'm sure I think nihal really needs
a win here he's just a lot lost two or
three games in a row so win would be you
to your first confidence and also it
would cut down mpl's lead to down to one
point but this is also what I find so
impressive about nihal having played as
many Blitz and bullet matches as I have
with him nobody is untiltable everybody
tells everybody reacts emotionally to a
disappointing string of games but when
you compare him to certain other players
I mean he is very very difficult to tilt
permanently right you know he might tilt
away a game or he might make a couple of
emotional moves but he's going to
stabilize really quickly and that makes
him a really really fearsome match
player
right for sure I do like the position
he's got in here and we still move
Bishop to E6 by mvl eyeing the pawn on
C4 the problem for black here dying is
the fact that black doesn't really have
any any active plans maybe what MVR
wants to do is play C5 at the right
moment and perhaps that's why nihal
played the move C5 himself he now wants
to go B4 92 to B3 to A5 and actually
it's always very uncomfortable to defend
upon on B7 I remember as a newer player
when I reached this structure with black
I think I'm totally safe because white
can never play B5 now that's not
entirely true there are situations when
white breaks through with B5 and
actually sacks upon but those are rare
but this Knight D2 Knight B3 Knight A5
maneuver completely changed my
understanding of these types of
positions now from Black's perspective I
think the only active plan the only
breakthrough is to prepare E5 so I would
actually play F6 drop my Bishop back to
F7 and play the move E5 and at the very
least you are cutting The Bishop's
influence over the position which will
allow you to play a move like Rook 8 to
B8 if necessary to guard the B7 Pawn but
look at Whitney Hall's doing meeting
fire with fire pushing that Bishop back
to E6
G4 was a great move by Neil as MPL was
just getting ready to play the movie E5
but now Neil goes G4 to Bishop probably
has to go back to E6 but then it's going
to be almost impossible to get the E5
push in again so nihal in full control
here and Diane this is so reminiscent of
that other game we saw in the London
gosh knee-haw playing on both sides of
the board it's like a practiced airline
pilot you know handling all the buttons
and pushing all the levers exactly when
he needs to push them to get the plane
off the ground but he's got a lot of
work left to do he plays the move F3
guarding the G4 Pawn restricting Black's
Knight MPL his pieces are stumbling over
each other he doesn't have enough space
to arrange his pieces the way that he
wants to arrange them Knight A4 Benjamin
Knight A4 and Knight B6 looks close to
devastating here
look straight at 94 I guess you have to
go in Rook a seven and after Knight B6
move the Rook to E8 as otherwise you run
out of squares but at some point Diane
that B5 push will come in the position
absolutely and a lot of patience is
required to convert a position like this
nothing comes fast here at some point
you might want to improve your position
with slower moves like King F2 and I
think newer players they struggle to
make those types of patient moves but
GMS are really good at that niho knows I
think exactly when to play aggressively
it went to tone it down a little bit and
and sit on his Advantage I think we are
going to see either Knight A4 or Knight
A5 and we do
Knight A5 Rook A7 forced
slowly but surely improve the position
and what does mvl do here I I don't know
you can move the bishop out of the way
maybe the 97 but even if you get E5 you
haven't really achieved a whole lot yet
but he goes 98. can B5 go B5 you're
dying yet oh my gosh Knight takes D5
Paul a takes there's Knight takes c66
and Knight takes E7 and he finds it dude
this is this is out of this world and I
mentioned earlier that B5 is possible
sometimes I've never seen this exact
idea can you play this on the board
really really quickly a takes B5 Knight
takes C6 The Rook on A7 is hanging
Knight takes E7 Intermezzo then you
recapture anyone and the problems don't
end there black is going to lose the D5
font as well this is filigree Precision
by nehal B5 is going to likely win the
game oh
exactly he takes with the April but now
1966 is just winning it's not the boss
of the exchange nah but this is not
going to cut it this is almost
resignable
yeah wow must have a win here just
rookie rookie it looks crushing you can
even consider a sacrifice with like
Bishops B5 and Knight takes D5 hitting
E7 and threatening Knight B6
and finally the the sick irony of this
game is that by the time MPL is finally
ready to push E5 he's now down in
exchange and you know the city has
burned to the ground so E5 is not going
to do anything why it's going to drop
the bishop back to G3 but still not over
nehal has to actually convert his extra
exchange I would also consider rook ca1
and you called it Bishop takes B5 on the
board and the Knight is heading to B6
we're gonna see resigns in a couple
moves here
Diane this is another master class in
the London he goes 96 forking the rook
and a bishop and after Rook did There's
Pawn C6 and black is completely lost
after visual moves there's Pawn C7 into
MBL just resigns I'm not exaggerating
when I say that if you told me that
nihal had played this game in classical
chess I would not be able to tell the
difference such was the quality of his
technical play in that end game
culminating in B4 B5 and a huge win not
only how he did it but the fact that he
scored that Victory brings mvl's lead
back to a point but the fact remains he
still faces a deficit both of these
players have had their incredible
moments thus far in this match
right and here we see a Taurus variation
nihal going for a very quick C5 to C4
I'm a little bit surprised that mvl
switched it up with the move 1 C4 the
caracon went pretty well for him in his
last game but maybe he wanted to avoid
the patchwork again
yeah and maybe he just wants a different
type of position and he's got it nihal
quickly pushes C4 driving that wedge
into the queen side and white counter
balancing that by positioning his pieces
in an active manner in the center Knight
jumps into E5 you can take the Knight
and play H6 but that is very ill-advised
just because the D5 Pawn is going to be
super super tender in the resulting
position
a really asking for trouble there so I
think nihal should just continue his
development and so he dealt with the
move Bishop to B4 you can capture with a
knight on D7 maybe black can even
recapture the queen and except these
double Pawns in exchange for the bishop
pair but instead of both sides just
Castle maybe move like Bishop 3 here to
put pressure on opponent D5 F4 very
risky move because you're weakening the
E4 square and you often see black taking
on C3 here automatically then you can't
play Knight E4 immediately although you
know sacking the queen is always nice
but not here so you could move the queen
away careful though because white is
threatening F5 unexpectedly trapping the
bishop
right so what about this thing maybe you
trade lc3 and then play the move Bishop
to F5 Bishop 5 currently is not a move
as it hangs the ball on D5 but just
trades first and then you get pretty
good control over the E4 Square
great idea takes and Bishop F5 clamping
down on that square preventing F5 New
Hall correctly pausing here this is an
important moment
and you know you could start with Bishop
takes C3 and then you know move first
think later kind of thing but it's a big
decision right giving away the bishop
pair changing the pawn structure by
definition is a committal decision that
has to be supplemented with a lot of
deep thought and he plays it
think again and there we have it great
call Benjamin and Bishop F5 on the board
and how is mvl now going to stoke the
Flames of his initiative in the center
will he play the obvious move I think
Bishop F3 there's some weird move Bishop
G4 trying to remove the bishops from the
board
what does he do
I think he has to be extremely careful
if black gets a couple moves here and
goes Queen to C7 followed by 94 all of a
sudden blank is doing great this Knight
can always be kicked away with F6 C3
will be weak and what is this darshan
bishop ever going to do it's gonna be
completely blocked by its own pawns and
I think it's important to point out
particularly for Less experienced
players Knight takes D7 Queen takes D7
Bishop takes F6 very very tempting the
thing is it's not enough to weaken your
opponent's Pawn structure you also have
to have the material the Personnel to
actually take advantage of that Bond
structure and if you do all of that
you're going to be left with only one
minor piece the black king can always
seek shelter on h8 and that's going to
have a lot less effect than it seems
Queen A5 nihal's response to Bishop F3
hitting the C3 Pawn unpinning the Knight
but potentially abandoning his King side
will mvl make him pay
right let's see what MPL can do here he
can still I mean in case 1967 now Neil
Hall can recapture the bishop or with an
eye that looks completely fine I wonder
why this com this move is given a
question mark by the computer looks fine
to me
looks fine to me as well looks very
logical as a matter of fact
um
Rook C1 might be necessary here I mean
you can't really afford to part waves
with the C3 Pawn black will then have a
extra protected passer on C4 so as
unpleasant as it is for a player like
mvl to play Rook C1 I think he might
have to bite the bullet here and and
guard the C3 Pawn with his teeth
right he can also defend opponent with a
move like Queen E1 and potentially swing
his Queen over to the king said although
I don't quite see how to do so just yet
so let's see what he will do perhaps he
has a move like G4 taking the bishop the
bishop can go to E4 but then you take
and you would love through a capture
with an eye but then you leave your
knight on D7 and there we go Diane great
move I really like I I warmed up to this
move the more I looked at it Bishop D3
nehal expected it in a positional Pawn
sacrifice trying to get this Knight off
the board and after Queen takes D3 He
can put his Rooks Benjamin on E8 and the
other Rook on C8 one Rook attacks the
weakness on C3 the other Rook Regan
forces the E4 Square I think black has
good practical compensation maybe mvl
should take on F6 and try to quickly
push through G5 and reduce Black's
control over the E4 square instead he
clings to his extra Pawn
all right because you want a pretty
logical move now rookie eight by nihal
putting pressure upon E3 and now in case
mvl goes for that idea there's always
the move Knight E4 I don't love the move
Bishop H4 he's keeping his Bishop on the
board perhaps he wants to go to E1
but the bishop will always be so
extremely passive there I think mvo
might be banking on a well-timed C4
break especially if the Black Knight
lands on e4 that leads to a crazy
tactical slugfest no he drops back to E1
going for Passive defense but Benjamin
C4 is not as much of a threat as it
appears because Black's Queen can drop
back to A6 and that's what nihal is
demonstrating with his last move C4
Queen A6 and that pawn will be lost
because the queen on D3 is undefended I
think mvl overlooked that detail and
black is achieving complete positional
dominance here once the Knight lands on
C4
I love what he's doing here the Knight
is going to land on C4 very very soon to
put on E3 will always be so extremely
weak dying and I don't see an active
plan here right he goes through kb1
perhaps he wants to take the pawn on B7
but even if you get the Rook there then
it's only one active piece all of your
other pieces are still extremely passive
also Knight C4 Rook takes B7 Knight E to
D6 exposing an attack on the E3 pawn and
if that pawn Falls White's position
collapses and you're always going to see
that he's gonna play Knight C4
yeah that looks like a nice move also
perhaps you can take the pawn on A2 but
maybe why can't cook up some counter
play so let's see what nihal is going to
do he's doing a good job in this game as
he's also up on the clock Knight C4
isn't forced you can also play Rook C4
but that carries a lot less oomph I
think than a knight on C4 which is
situated on this beautiful post hitting
the backward Pawn on E3 and cooperating
beautifully with its brother on e4 nihal
taking more time than I expected him to
I thought he'd play Knight C4 quickly
maybe Rook takes B7 is giving him more
pause than we expected
yeah so let's see the Poland A2
currently can be taken but why it's
gonna go rookie one and get supermarket
and he goes for it Knight to C4 and MPL
instantly gives up his light squared
Bishop Rook takes E4 Bishop F2 probably
going for Passive defense now mvl's
position is solid I mean it's not easy
to break this down but I feel like with
that monster Knight on C4 now with a
rook beautifully situated on The Outpost
there should be some way to eventually
crack through maybe nihal should go B5
and A6 to shut down potential counter
playing the queen side yeah he plays B6
same same idea
yeah this position looks gross for mvl
he's up a pawn but he has not a single
activated upon E3 this week the pawn on
C3 is weak designer C4 is an absolute
Beast Daya I think any player here would
just correct with white the only player
I can think of to hold on here is Hikaru
oh yeah and Hikaru would be playing this
for a win with the white pieces right
you'll be like Oh I'm up a party and
playing for a win you know I'll produce
her you mean
rotate the queen to D7 hit the G4 upon
the juicer and G4 push H5 carve out the
big Square on F5
and Blake's also got a nice Bastion on
C4
red bash on e4 as well now we can try to
carve out square five H five sacrificing
a juicer and then rotating Queen d75
okay politics H5 does look like a nice
move for mvl this one is probably going
to be regained pretty soon by nihal but
now he gets the open G4 to at least
create some counter play
absolutely have to use the G file right
you have to use yes you have crumbs here
that you have to pick up from the ground
but mvl I love the move Rook G1 such a
heads up move he's not losing hope and
queen takes G5 Rook G5 gets a little bit
messy Benjamin Queen F3 in that position
can be met with Rook to G3 sending the
queen back to H5 I think that nehal
missed that detail and he might have to
play F6 here uh to cover the G5 square
but then MBL has H6 and things get a
little bit more complicated
H6 can still be met with G6 but the
black pawns also get a little bit tender
nihal yeah like I said the deadline
might just be a repetition Rook G5 and
Rook G3 there is the move worktics for
Diane and after Rook takes uh Queen
takes Rotex I think black has an edge
there in the end game but white can now
give up the queen for the two rocks
looks very scary for why not gonna lie
Queen takes D3 Rook takes C8 King H7
apparently there's this crazy move H6
throwing the pawn in to induce
weaknesses near Black's King you have to
activate the Rooks if you're white and
you don't have a lot of time to do it
because nihal is threatening the move
Knight to D2 and there is a classic
right triangle on F3 this is a very
difficult position to defend practically
speaking
I think so too I like the move H6 that
you suggest that in case you take the
king there's Checkmate although oh you
know you have to clean your checks but
it's checked now let's put it that way
there's G6 but then maybe I can go
Bishop H4 to F6 as a threaten Checkmate
on h8 once again you can maybe take with
the and there we go if you take the pawn
eg8 and how do you stop this black could
get checkmated here I can't believe that
mvl has managed to obtain this amount of
counter play it's anybody's game at this
point G6 Bishop H4 threatens Bishop F6
White's King is safer than it looks it
can drop back to H1 but instead he's
gone rookie seven and can nehal drop
back to F5 hitting F4 and defending F7
at the same time or Knight D6
queen of five looks like a nice move
hitting a four and defending of seven
Knight E6 as well and now White's pieces
don't fully coordinate MPL picks up the
pawn on A7 but maybe not mvl just takes
here or it takes on C3 what does mvl
here to do to create counter play he
needs to get his Bishop into the game he
goes Rook G2
loses
how did he do that
we were joking that the only player to
hold this and actually play for the win
was he covered but mvl managed to flip
this one around and managed to score win
there and the way that he did that is
even more impressive it's not like Niha
made one blunder you know he Mao slipped
or he hung his Queen no it happened in
stages first MBL got his Rook to the
g-file then he managed to go for that
two Rooks for Queen position which was
really hard to assess properly then he
used his Rooks to knock Black's Knight
off of D6 and finally he found Bishop H4
on demand to set up an Unstoppable
mating that amazing again as mvl reaches
a three-point lead this is a big game
suddenly Benjamin this is the last game
of the five minute portion nihal has to
stop the bleeding
yeah no for sure I mean a three-point
Elite is not insurmountable especially
if they enter into the puller portion
but again especially for knee house
confidence he needs some wins here I
don't really love the position here he's
got him with white it feels like black
finally has a good game here against
Solana because all of their pieces are
pretty active in Tanya in the last game
we were praying for mvl to get that E5
push in and here he's got it right out
of the gates
but it's one of those things right the
cookie tastes best when you're forbidden
to eat it when when there's the cookie
jar on the table
it's uh it suddenly doesn't taste as
good but this position tastes pretty
good for MBL as he sinks his teeth into
E4 and he's threatening Knight to C3
which will give him the bishop pair
maybe Queen E1 here should be considered
by nihal he goes 91 so he does stop
Knight C3 and he's heading for D3 with
his Knight he likes this maneuver I've
seen him do this in many of these London
positions 91 ID3
that was a really bad move by MPL I have
no idea why he reduced the tension in
the worst possible version and it's the
second time that he's missed that Bishop
capture on C7 remember that game where
nihal won the pawn on D5 it happened in
a very similar way and it also featured
the move Bishop takes C7 but as in that
last game it doesn't end the game it's
not like Neal wins a pawn and that's it
the position remains very very
complicated
yeah he still has to finish this one off
and he's filled to do so in some of the
games before this he's got a nice
position but you know for the moment mvl
has the best repair if he can somehow
consolidate with moose like F5 and King
hate he's not doing too bad as the pawn
D5 is also a weakness so let's see what
Nihao will try to do here but Diane you
said it before he blundered this tactic
and you actually see beginners do this
quite a lot they just forget about this
bishop on H2 which can sometimes take a
rook over here it's one of the appeals
of the London system you know the
tactics can come at any side of the
board Knight TV5 though I didn't like I
there wasn't actually any need to move
the knight from D4 because it wasn't
touchable I don't know if that's a word
but the pawn on C5 was pinned now the
Knight on B5 is in a world of hurt A6 is
threatened this old friend of ours night
before to C3 could come knocking if the
Knight leaves B5 and I don't know where
it's gonna go from B5 you might have to
go A4 A6 Knight A3 but
that still likes like that still looks
like a good solution instead it goes
Queen C2 hitting that F5 nice move by
mvl defending the Knight and E4 and
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
dying I like your move A4 but perhaps
black and gold A6 kick the Knight back
and then go B5 to make sure that it
cannot go to C4 the pawn cannot be taken
as that would hang the Knight on A3 and
I'm really impressed with how mvl
responds to his blunders this isn't
talked about enough but that is a great
strength of a lot of top players on the
rare occasions when they do blunder
something directly
um they they immediately recuperate they
immediately tell themselves okay now I
have a different task in front of me and
mvl has done a great job of stabilizing
himself and quickly finding the best
practical way to respond and that's
given him directly a couple of points
now A6 and B5 looks like an interesting
way to fight against the Knight on B5
from rejoining society via C4
yeah for the moment the pawn on D5 is
Untouchables that will lead to Bishop to
C4 and lose the Rook so he goes King h8
attacking the pawn let's see what nihal
is going to do here opponent D5 is
threat and Bishop C4 is a move then
there might also be 92 in The Rook in a
forest draft
why was Knight D2 not possible on the
previous move I wonder maybe it's
because of something like D6 and you all
would have sacrificed The Exchange but
now with Black's King in complete safety
I agree Knight D2 is a force to be
reckoned with
I think after 92 there might have been
B4 you attacked the queen and belong to
the diagonal for the moment black has to
take with the queen then there's Knight
D3 attacking the queen and after the
queen steps back then you have time for
Rook D1 and black has lost valuable time
great cough that was indeed the reason
now again Nihao struggling on the clock
down to two minutes the pawn on D5 hangs
the Knight on B5 is Awkward the bishop
pair is strong black controls a lot of
key squares on the queen side and the
trend of the game again moving in mvl's
favor nothing remains of nihal's
Advantage garnered after he won the pawn
on D5 he's misplayed this
yeah B5 great find here by nvl
completely restricting the 983 now he's
ready to regain upon on D5 and I think
blacks is better black is the bishop
pair especially this bishop on G7 which
is on a post is so strong on the long
diagonal all of the pieces falling into
place here with
blacks pieces achieving Superior
coordination space Advantage but I at
the same time it doesn't feel like white
is anywhere near lost maybe not even
worse if nehal handles this well I think
he needs to get rid of that Knight on e4
that Knight on e4 is like a bone and
White's throat you have to find an
opportunity maybe to drop one of your
Knights over to D2 probably the F3
Knight to keep the C3 Square protected
exactly if you've got an ibd2 there will
be Knight C3 which is extremely
unpleasant so maybe you go another C2
maybe here or you trade on D5 First
bishop D3 can also be considered by
Diana look at the clock nihal chopping
down to a minute and 16 seconds and MPL
still has three and a half minutes on
this clock yeah mvl's time management
throughout this entire hour and a half
has been nothing short of superb
right so Knight fd2 offering
illustrative Knights I guess mvl has to
trade this authorized by traits himself
and gives black a weakness on e4 and
there we go 1962 is on the board
New Hall recaptures with a rook trying
to soften up the C5 Pawn he needs to
procure some targets that he can attack
with his pieces so far I think nihal is
doing a stellar job of maintaining the
kind of Integrity of his position I am
worried about Black's Pawn majority on
the queen side eventually in some
in-game black could push C4 but that's
still far away as MBL establishes his
Queen on B4 obviously you cannot take on
C5 because then Knight on D2 will hang
right so perhaps you have to move your
knight first and that is what nihal
doesn't have three not a pawns under
attack so MPL played the move Rook 2 C8
and the B3 Pawn is hanging I think MPL
is still in the driver's seat Diana but
he has to be careful this and I can
always jump in there might be some there
might be some tricks there
yes currently though nihal has to figure
out
how to defend that B3 Pawn now you could
sacrifice it you could try to go Queen
A2 or queen D3 and he does going for
activity but mvl doesn't even think
about capturing that pawn instead their
C4 pass Pawn created the square on D6 is
now under his control and Niha has to
move back slink away with his Queen this
is starting to seem closer and closer to
winning for mvl
yeah this looks pretty nice reveal a C3
setting upon a motion Knight D4 blocking
the bishop on G7 but maybe you just go
Bishop F7 keep the bishop nice and
active or G8 these Bishops are far away
Diane but they operate as snipers
Bishops are so well from from a distance
textbook illustration of the power of
long range pieces here
maybe you have four here two weaken the
spawn on E3 a little bit you cannot take
us at least the Knight on D4 hanging
great whole board awareness by you
Benjamin and by mvl F4 creates a new set
of problems for nehal who finds an
excellent defensive move Knight back to
C2 exclamation mark awarded and deserved
but the problems are only beginning for
white because if you allow the black
queen to land on F4 there's also Bishop
B5 The Rook on C1 is under Fire Queen to
D2 could be a big problem 20 seconds for
any Hall also a problem can he stay
afloat here
he goes Knight at E3 maybe he wants to
go Knight D5 Bishop b55 for the moment
can be met with G3 also now with Knight
G4 and maybe that's why mvl goes for f8
he wants to stop nihal from Ever playing
G3
that would now hang the bishop on F3 the
bishop on F3 is also paralyzed but Queen
D3 may be setting up an exchange
sacrifice on C3 which would I think give
Neal Hall excellent practical drawing
chances
exactly I think that he should be able
to draw there but it can look at the
clock he's got 16 seconds mvl has two
minutes and 15. so Queen D4 offering the
trade of Queens nihal should be able to
hold but It's Tricky
yeah I think objectively this is
holdable and so far he's doing an
excellent job of avoiding blunders and
keeping his position stable he's
basically going back and forth between
C2 and E3 but he can't do that forever
drops his Bishop to E2 rook in
infiltrate D2 maybe white should involve
his King via F1 and E1
right I like to move rookie too maybe at
the Ramon Bishop E3 and C2 and then okay
official C4 54 threatening Bishop takes
the experience NSC to it and there's
nothing you can do
King H2 gives up F2 he tries Knight C4
but he's given up the F2 Pawn now it's
objectively winning for black
H2
see tutors King G3 so how exactly do you
win this time I wouldn't rush I would go
King G7 I wouldn't go King F7 because
that allows Knight D6 and ib5 I would go
King G7 King F6 and then think just or
maybe H5 improve your position slowly
and with three seconds I think niho's
Position will just collapse on its own
H5 is such a nasty with the Pokemon good
H4 and wait without oh he's pondered the
pawn
he's blundered the pawn he's allowed
Knight P5
nihal might be getting away with the
draw here what a throw by mvl
he needed to step away with his Bishop
on the previous move so that Knight B5
wouldn't come with Tempo now Bishop E5
King G1 and The Rook is hanging and you
can't move the rook and simultaneously
defend the C3 Pawn now it's a draw
right maybe MPL can play something like
Bishop B3 Rook take C3 and rookie two
they're still check mating at his
against fighting and white only has two
seconds
he's gotta try to get the bishop to G3
still trying still dangerous
94. but I think there's no tactics I
would go Bishop two and Checkmate
King H7 no no wait pretty good you have
to stop Rook of Fate King F7 or F7
because there's no check on c78 it's
over Bishop F2 is going to win The Rook
after Rook D2 Rook F2 and Rook D2 that's
easy that is the game the Knight is lost
oh and take us tonight and that's it I
am
yeah now it's easy too
wow what a game and MPL opens up a
three-point lead going into the three
plus one portion and you called it I
think
um Benjamin where nihal found that
seemingly drawing idea but mvl didn't
lose hope and the fact that he left
himself with a minute on his clock
allowed him to figure out the best
winning attempt it is six to three nvl
is on a tear he's winning with both
colors he's winning in many different
ways and his form from his first match
has carried over nihal has a lot of
changes Benjamin that he has to make
going into the three plus one
yeah he for sure will have to play
faster I mean he ends up in these
situations where he has a couple seconds
on his clock and feel on the other hand
still has a couple minutes and even when
nihal saves the draw uh MPL puts
practical problems and it's just too
much for Neil to handle it is indeed and
we will see if he has what it takes to
come back in the hour uh that we will be
playing of three plus one now the SEC is
made possible by the efforts of these
amazing players but also by our
presenting sponsor coinbase do you by
any chance wish that your financial
systems were as fast and as smart as the
2023 speed Chess Championship presented
by coinbase they can be check out
coinbase.com update the system that's
coinbase.com update the system today or
use x Glam coinbase in chat to learn
more we think coinbase we're making the
SCC possible okay we will have the three
plus one portion of this amazing match
in the SEC presented by coinbase don't
go anywhere we'll be feedback in just a
couple of minutes
[Music]
foreign
for every daily puzzle
[Music]
got it Bishop G7 King G7 Queen E5 Queen
E4 and the end white wins a piece
nailed it
everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games
hey we're trying to have a lesson here
you need to get out of here recently
more kids have been playing chess than
ever in school but sadly we've learned
that they may not always be playing
chess at the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
[Music]
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
holds a three-point lead upon the
conclusion of the five plus one segment
here in the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase I'm Jim Daniel
meriditski alongside Grandmaster
Benjamin Bach commentating his second
match of the day you're a trooper
Benjamin what do you make of the 90
minutes of Amazing action that we have
just watched
right so right now MPL has a pretty
dominant lead in the match he's up three
games Diana doesn't tell the whole story
though I think Neil had some great
chance to at least be even or maybe have
a slide lead himself but he keeps
dropping down on time and MPL
capitalizes honest chances
well mvl one of the most experienced
players in the speed Chess Championship
he's been terrorizing the chess field
for many years let's take a look at a
resume he is the 2021 World Blitz
Champion an incredible achievement to
boot over 2800 Peak rating he was French
Champion as early as 2007. just think
about how many years ago that was how
long mvl has been really really good and
he is just one of
the most fun players to watch uh
Benjamin and we watch him on camera
there
for sure and he's also been the world
number one on the blitz rankings dying
he's his speed rating in Blitz diet is
29.48 that is insane
be still my beating heart and I think he
just showed us why a lot of changes that
new Hall will have to make we now have
an hour of three minutes plus a one
second increment Maxime has the white
pieces in the 10th game of the match and
here we go nihal a third opening trotted
out a modern and I mentioned this before
the match he likes these perk modern
structures playing for a win with the
black pieces
right I'm a little bit surprised by this
move Bishop C4 by MPL usually you play
Neta 3 first now it's in there six and
now he goes Queen E2 defending the pawn
so nvl seems really reluctant to put a
sign on F3 here
H3 are you I think you are weirded out
by this I am as well he's delaying the
development of his Knights but I don't
like this I what is he doing black is a
good position here
right because now Nihao was like okay
can go Bishop G4 let me go B6 and Bishop
A6 attacking the queen provoking this
awkward move scene
E6 Grand move you're starting to take on
D5 and you can't ever capture the pawn
and if you were captured with the e-pawn
you're running into Knight takes D5 that
Bishop on A6 is so well placed I think
nihal has to seize the opportunity to
play E6 because if he delays even by one
move mvl gets a chance to Castle and
then E6 can be met with d-take C6 and I
think white emerges with a fine position
great stuff by nihal in the early going
perhaps MPL has to go politics E6 right
now but Neil can recapture okay we'll
see Knight C3 in case of takes you have
to take with the EPO and then rookie 8
looks awkward I guess there's still
Bishop B3 but die this this looks like a
weird opening from White
although maybe e takes D5 was rushed
nihal could actually have started with
rookie 8 setting up the threat of he
takes D5 that would have compelled mvl
to be the one to take on E6 and that in
turn would have weakened some dark
squares in the center but that ship has
sailed we have a different Pawn
structure now and Bishop H6 is a classic
idea yes you give away your fan kettled
Bishop but you Garner for yourself a big
Square on E5 you weaken White's Pawn
structure maybe white should prevent 95
with Bishop A4
right now the bishop on B3 is kind of a
pawn and with Bishop before you can
trade it off for the Knight on D7 it
will make it much more difficult for
black to ever take control over the
square but instead he goes Rook A1 maybe
now before I think he should try
to get rid of that Bishop
King G7 there was a nice move by Newhall
95 immediately was not possible you
would have dropped the F6 at night now
95 is I would go so far as to call it a
positional threat if black establishes a
presence on the E5 Square white will run
out of active ideas on the king side and
from a purely strategical standpoint
black is better so mvl has to keep the
legs churning here maybe takes in rookie
through Rook F3 to set up pressure down
the f-file and he does it I think 95 was
rushed as now there's no good way to
defend against Rook of three then you
and I will be under attack and the F7
Pawn will be hanging as well so I don't
know what my channel has to do here this
looks like he's in big trouble
he missed rookie 3 and rookie 3 is
devastating Queen to D4 here runs into
Knight E2 or even E5 so that doesn't
help either
holy smokes this turned around quickly
rookie 7 Rook F3 Knight takes E4 Rook
takes F7 check and black could get
checkmated there
oh takes up seven and Bishop 876 the
pawn yes maybe now Bishop before the
Knight is actually kind of Trapped
where'd he go and if the ninth gets
traded off there will always be Rook D
Rook to f8 check mania's Daya is there
perhaps Bishop C4 although I guess what
I can always take and that's what takes
on a point you can take an E7 throw in
Bishop B6 and then take in a form I'd
suggest that we play this put this on
the analysis board but but I don't think
we should because it's going to be put
on the real board isn't that game over
47. Rook of Fate is made knehals tilted
Cafe
we're Rook G8 What A Move six though
Queen E3 but Dia this is winning Queen
E3 G5 Rook takes and Rook of six and
nihal just resigns and Benjamin this is
the kind of position that you would want
to get when you sacrifice a piece or
Rook white is actually a pawn up in that
final position that might be the most
depressing thing of all even if white
doesn't Checkmate instantly it's just
winning in the long run what a game to
kick off the three-minute segment and
more bad news for nehal he had a good
position out of the opening it was a
misplayed perk by mvl but missing that
rookie through Rook F3 idea completely
changed the game
exactly yeah now nihal was doing
absolutely fine but 95 was a little bit
rushed and after rookie three he all of
a sudden had unsolvable problems but he
did go down very quickly Diana
Rogue GA though was a sexy move just
moving The Rook away setting up Queen f8
and mvl's tactical Vision it's normally
monstrously good but in the SCC he's
spotting these tactics in the span of a
millisecond
right and here we see them going for
this job of london-ish set up again
Nihao going for C4 breaking down MPL
Center you can go E4 here followed by a
five but that's going to open up this
light this dark Bishop on H2
yeah that's a big decision there E4 very
committal
and instead MBL keeps the status quo in
the center but wait a second
oh he wants Bishop takes H3 at the end I
think I think he wants Bishops
oh I think she's six though another
inner veto and nihal takes it he takes
the palm
maybe I'm Bill just forgot that Bishop
E6 cuts the contact between the queen
and the E5 Pawn this is a big chance for
any Hall to seize the advantage out of
the opening
yeah he does he takes the pun
yeah
he is gonna take here
because white skin is so much exposed
but you can always Point your Bishop on
G4 and block the G file one crucial
detail Benjamin after Bishop takes H3
Knight takes G6 Queen G5 Forks the
Knight and the pawn on G2 but the Knight
can drop back to F4 and that is such a
powerful response to a fork when you
move one of the pieces back and defend
the other piece instead the hall takes
or mvl takes a different approach D
takes C4 opening up the D file and
threatening Knight D6 to E4
okay what now the problem is that it has
to move like Queen C2 you don't have a
good way to hang on to this one I think
the Knight ef3 is way too timid just
moving the night back voluntarily now
black can play the move B5 as C6 is no
longer hanging and material for the
moment is even even though white should
have a small Edge
I like that nihal is playing a little
bit faster in general in the three
minute portion that is encouraging
uh what do we make of this position
who's playing for the advantage here
from a strategical perspective it's
probably white because White's got the
four on two in the center and Black's
got the slightly damaged Pawn structure
on the queen side on the other hand
Black's minor pieces are nicely put
together in the center the Knight on D5
is well established but so is it's
vis-a-vis on D4 as well as the bishop
that nihal just put on the long diagonal
yeah I like the move Bishop 3 putting
some pressure on the Knight on D5 maybe
now A4 you kind of go B4 as it hangs
upon a C4 and white is threatening to
use rookie one first maybe this gives
empty all the time to go Knight B6 as
the C6 bonus definitely goes Knight
before D3
and he also wants to enable the move C5
which would chase the Knight out of the
center I think he should throw in the
move C5 forcing kneehal's Knight to drop
back to E2 and after Knight D3 black is
on the move here
yeah C5 on the board 92 I like the move
Knight D3 I guess you have to go Queen
where do you go Queen C3 or queen C2 it
all looks a little bit iffy
Queen C2 might run into Bishop F5
setting up the threat of a discovered
attack on the queen that Queen has no
good home Queen C3 you have to reckon
with B4 so he plays Quincy to Bishop F5
out of a cannon the instant response
great move with everybody until now
Knight except through is a threat
hitting the queen on C2 and The Rook on
D1 E4 is not available I should just
take so maybe
I mean Knight G3 do you still take an oh
my God look at this guy it takes takes
kingdix of two queen E3 and Knight can
you put this on the board for newer
players can we put this on the board
there's a sick line and this is what
nihal is struggling with right now
Knight takes F5 look at this geometry
bang and a mate on G3 isn't this sick
even without both of Black's Rooks this
would still be a Checkmate the only
important pieces is the strongest tandem
in the game the queen and the Knight
what they are capable of doing defies
belief sometimes
exactly yeah the queen and Knight combo
is so strong so let's see how nihal will
deal with this maybe he has to move his
Queen but Queen C3 looks awkward then
there's B4 and your queen he goes Knight
G3 Diane maybe he still has Bishop D5
authorized he'll just be dead last year
and we're seeing Knight takes F2 Bishop
D5 only move he's found it and after
King f8 you have to go King f8 so that
the queen can't move up to C3 with track
that is actually very easy to miss but
white can still points
exactly wow
so what do you do there so maybe Knight
F7 you cover the square you can take the
Knight but then you take a D1 and queen
shade is no longer Checkmate as there
will be king takes F7
I think you're right well first of all
you have to play King f8 otherwise you
drop at the very least a minor P so
Bishop B6 here white will simply take on
E6 and take on F2 what a counter blow
Uncorked by nihal that this is what he
was spending his time on finding Bishop
D5 check and now Queen C3 a very
important follow-up we've got
pandemonium on the board but mvl stays
on top he finds that F7
gray move now the Knight on F2 Camry
thing but then there will be Rook takes
D5 nihal takes on a five first I suppose
he has to take the Knight as it's still
attacking his Rook as he won and after
65 it feels like like it's just a very
clean Pawn
he is and B4 another amazing response
forcing the queen back establishing a
favorable Pawn structure on the queen
side finally the smoke is cleared feels
like black is somewhat better here and
the Knight can head to E4 with great
effect
and 94 is a nice smooth and I can
potentially go to C3 as well wait that
was just a Pawn on D4 but MPL did not
take it
yeah that pawn on E3 was capturable
I think Dania he was already hovering
over the move Knight to E4 so that as
soon as Neil moved he released it but he
probably just taking the pawn there that
might have been winning he's still
better though the F5 Pawn is a weakness
nihal would kill to get his Knight to H4
unfortunately he's got no way to
actually secure that square a second
time I think he's trying he's trying to
go Queen E1 and Knight H4 but that's
slow Knight C3 Queen E1 and okay mvl
could also drop his King back to h8 and
try to take the sting out of the move
Knight H4 he might have the response
Rook to D1 in response to Knight H4
there
really want us an idea in general to
trade out the rest upon a2s hang both
players down to 17 seconds a piece more
or less this is nihal's territory these
time scrambles he's so good at them he
hangs his hat on them but mvl has shown
every ability to stay on the same even
on better terms than nihal in these time
pressure situations Knight back to E4
there's a check on B2 blocked by black
screen the end game is lost for white
too many weaknesses Queen C3 right so
Quincy yeah Queen C3 gray move maybe you
can even consider capturing with the
people and it goes Queen G3 also a nice
move Queen E2 maybe there's Knight C3
again he goes King G8
attacks first
on the board
but the queen is not going anywhere
maybe just start pushing Queen F6 Queen
E1 he might be going for a Queenie for
now and there it is
gonna flag he flagged
what a game doing MPL had a win and
after that he throws away to draw
froze he froze after Queen A4 he saw the
threat of Queen E8 check he panicked and
that is a heartbreaker for Maxime and
that's a disturbing sign going into the
bullet right he has to he has to be
better in these time scramble situations
because you're gonna get more of them I
think as this match winds toward the
bullet
yeah and losing on time is just
unacceptable you just gift a point to
your opponent MPL should have won that
game and said he loses and now it's down
to three still according to lead for MPL
but nihal is back in the match
indeed he is and we have a very quiet
position I think both players just
taking some deep breaths mvl has white
pieces here on uh you know relatively
symmetrical modern I always feel like
white is a tiny bit better here because
his dark scored Bishop is generally
better than its counterpart on G7 which
is you know staring down the barrel of
your own Pawn on E5 but the advantage is
at best very very very slight
exactly black often goes here for almost
like Knight H5 followed by Knight of
four then white has to think like hey do
I give my bishop or not you get the
bishop pair you give the bishop to
Blackbird in return black white does get
this move E5 instead we see the move B5
by nihal and Bishop to E6 and mvl just
keeps the Bishops on the board for now
with the move Knight F3
H6 by New Hall covering the G5 Square
obviously Knight takes well not
obviously actually Knight takes C5 has
to be calculated and Knight takes E5
Bishop takes B3 Knight takes C6 I'm too
lazy to calculate I don't think it works
I think black moves the queen away and
then has Bishop B3 back to C4 with Tempo
garnering two pieces for a rook
right at the end of it all white will
get a rook and two pawns for the minor
pieces but I think the minor pieces will
be better in the middle game but it's
certainly worth consideration and that
is why mvl has paused think here
Bishop oh Queen C2
repositioning the queen supporting the
bishop now Bishop takes B3 I think will
be met with a takes B3 much like in that
London system game where white wants to
open up the a file and he doesn't really
mind doubled pawns on the queen side one
of the drawbacks of blacksmove B5 is
that it does create potential Targets on
the queen side nihal keeps the queen
side closed and mvl says let's open that
baby up
yep so we see nihal his Bishop on G7 was
passed so he rerouted to f8 which D3 I
like how MPL was playing this I feel
like he's got a slight Edge black has
some witnesses upon E5 is always hanging
the pawn on A5 is a little bit of a
weakness maybe Viking consider Bishop E6
at the right moment and then taking on
B5 and perhaps that is why nihal played
Rook D to B8
all hands on deck knee-haul controlling
his pawns from behind with his Towers
but mvl seizing the opportunity to claim
control of the only open file on the
board the D file
right so we see rugby Stone by Niha I
wonder what exactly the idea is maybe
just making sure that the Rook is never
hanging on this light Square maybe MPL
can now reroute this time maybe like 91
although 93 is not available I should
hang the pawn on e4
yeah very interesting maneuvering game
here as both sides kind of gearing up
for the subsequent battle I think this
is the stage of the game where we've got
this cat and mouse battle but the
position's starting to open up a little
bit as mvl trades on B5 and routing his
Knight to C5 so we're gonna get our
first peace imbalance of the game which
piece is stronger
right I would think usually the mission
as the bishop has more scope instead of
the move Rook seed wait maybe now
there's a queen C4 heading the bishop
does knee held just going to pawn you or
perhaps maybe six six
and he plays we might get further
liquidation with Queen takes C4 that'll
lead to an end game probably equal right
I would think right
yeah the Knight on e4 is pretty active
black doesn't have any weaknesses now
white is time to go F3 I don't know the
pawn E5 is a bit of a weakness so I
think npl might still have a slight edge
here also I think his King will often be
safer here on H2 than his black
counterpart on G7 with Rook d8 coming
I thought Rook d8 would really have
accentuated just how weak Black's King
could be Bishop f8 check Queen D2 you
know the storm clouds kind of start to
gather but mvl takes a more defensive
posture with Rook D2 I think he's trying
to take the sting out of the move Knight
F4 preparing to double Rooks on the
default and this doesn't mean he's not
going to play Rook d8 he might be saving
that move for a rainy day
yeah I'm kind of surprised with the move
rookie too because usually you double up
your Rooks to eventually enter but he
could have entered there right away now
rudit can be met with about a quintix
before it takes before the game yeah
yeah you can enter but you're gonna exit
pretty quickly you're gonna exit the
game after Rook d8 I would play King H2
yeah just get the king out of the firing
line of blocks Queen and Knight now
we're gonna see moves like H5 again I
think we've entered the kind of kg
maneuvering stage where both players are
trying to maximize their pieces and
their pawns before the position opens up
again and it might never open up right
we might just get some sort of a
positional draw here but I don't think
so
yeah actually H5 would deliver G3 in the
United States so maybe G5 so and there
we go then I can jump back to G6 I think
an excellent move by nihal is the Knight
will now certainly help in the defense
great call mvl
tries to take the ladies off the board
that B5 Pawn right that's an easy pawn
to forget about but it is backward and
it can be targeted by a rook from B5 and
I don't think nehal liked that end game
and feel though repositioning his Queen
to a beautiful Central Square where it
Lords over the entire position
supervising both sides of the board
yeah I like Queen E3 rookie okay this is
inviting Rook to D6 they're still Queen
C4 for knee-hal but it's starting to
look a little bit tricky maybe just
rookie two preemptively defending the
pawn on B2 and there we go I love the
way mvl is interspersing attacking moves
like Rook D6 with more prophylactic
defensive moves like Rook D2 restricting
the scope of Black's pieces that Knight
on G6 is also a sad product it doesn't
have access to any active scores because
of the Pawn on G3 King G2 now would be
another solid defensive move he plays it
nihal staying afloat here maybe trying
to move his own King away and set up
tactics like Knight F4 but another queen
trade offer by mvl
yeah and this way nihal cannot avoid the
queen trade although he does so but he
has done B5 that's a pretty big price to
pay down here
yeah Bishop f8 not possible because the
queen is protected a third offer of a
queen trade and this one cannot be
refused
okay H4 they're they're good Queens off
maybe bishop B7 to make sure that this
Knight can jump at a four square and
then you also take the bottom E5 that
looks like a win for MV he goes from D6
instead
okay
he's on the board there are always going
to be chances
C4 Bishop C3 looks like a solid way to
defend the B2 Pawn instead he throws in
a check but he sends the king to a safer
Square Bishop A3 careful careful Rook
takes A3 and B2 has to be watched out
for I think nihal has great practical
chances now he's finally managed to
Break Free with his Knight
right and now you can go Rook to h8 some
sort of check mating ideas
E6 Maybe
right I like that idea because you can
take over here and then go see for after
kingy G6 you can take
okay it should be seven maybe going
after to spawn
and there we go he is he plays it and
feel gonna win a third Pawn
Rook H4 checking G3 doesn't do anything
he all has to go back in shame don't
take that I think because if F6 Bishop
D6 or Bishop back to A3
and it's technically winning now maybe
five seconds
okay I don't like e5s then there's 94
but Rook B6 nice controlling move maybe
just C4
okay Rebecca or there
okay this one is not over just yet maybe
just take the Palm but there's H4 that
gives this King a little bit more
Breathing Room f45 Gray movie mvl 5.
excellent pushing the Knight away now he
should be comfortably winning nihal
clinging to his last source of counter
play but he's about to lose that too
mvl's taking all his pawns all of them
there goes
six Wade
crazy things happening here Rook B8 and
black would be in the checkmating that
but where does the Knight go I don't see
the square root B8 this is Ruby eight
and that's checkmate
it's mate Bishop takes F6 no stalemate
too many pieces and rookie trade is
Unstoppable and that was an excellent
performance by Maxime in time pressure
there were some inaccuracies but he
never let the advantage slip and his
lead balloons to four
yeah four points is not insurmountable
just yet but we see that MPL can hang
with nihal in a Time scramble so even if
nihal is hoping for a comeback in bullet
FPL it can I can fight there as well
this is starting to enter that territory
where nehal really needs a string of
Victories to get himself back in this
match four points is a lot
okay and we are yet again I'm a little
sick of this opening I feel like I want
a little variety from nihal but we keep
getting different versions of this
position and now we're getting something
a lot more tactical with an early Pawn
sack by mvl does he have enough for that
pawn on the queen side Bishop B4 maybe
looks like he does
yeah Rook see a nice move taking the
bishop Bishop has to slide back to G3
maybe bishop B4 setting up 94 or 95 and
wide hasn't developed hasn't completed
their development just yet
Bishop before he plays the night before
which I think is less effective because
of Rook C1
and maybe he wants to send the other
night over to E4 he's definitely making
a lot of noise on the Queensland it is
definitely scary for white
yeah I wonder what should white should
do there after 94. maybe after 94 you
just play Bishop B2 black intake on C3
but you recapture Over The Rook black
takes you to the pawn Knight takes A2 an
eagle King D2 and all of a sudden the
Knight on A2 is off
I think that's a very important line and
that might have been overlooked or
underestimated by Maxine but first of
all nehal has to find Rook C1 that's not
the only move you could also play King
D2 but that runs right into 94 check and
then maybe some sort of an Intermezzo
with the black Rook coming to C2 he goes
to D1 instead
that looks risky maybe like Bishop C2
your King has to move like let's hit a
D2 and then 94 and again after this
trade like it goes Bishop B7 but this
gives nihal time to consolidate
A3 he wants to drop the Knight back to
D5 I think and pave the way for a rook
infiltration on C2 I still am of the
opinion that black has good practical
chances but it does seem like the game
is trending now in the Hall's Direction
and feel not lighting the fire yet on
the queen side
and Neil is so good in these these
positions he's with his pieces on the
last couple of rings but he can cover
all of these squares he goes like
probably 91 on the left at the fine
moments maybe A3 kicking the night away
but he goes bishop and now Bishop C2
your idea Benjamin 94 clears off the C
file and there's a lot of mating threats
there white spots you can even and he
goes for you cannot take the king is
that's Checkmate a woman but 94 and 1963
black gets great compensation here he's
all over him on the queen side he's
going to win that pawn on A2 and then
he's gonna have connected passers which
are so dangerous because of how poorly
White's pieces are coordinated Knight A2
anyway slices off the connection between
the rook and the pawn he goes the other
way that was wrong
because now there's King D2 you take the
bishop which has to move to like A4 you
cannot move back to this diagonal black
certainly still has compensation before
might come in at the right moment but I
think mvl's misses chance here
yeah Knight A2
was incredibly powerful in that position
it would have won that A3 Pawn now he's
got to decide which direction he's going
to take with his Bishop Bishop A4 Bishop
B3 it's a tough position for black to
navigate now
I would put my Bishop on A4 it's just a
little bit further awake and never be
hanging
uh Bishop E3 also possible to let you
potentially want to go B4 and then it's
not hanging on the A4 Square so let's
see which one mvl is going to go for
who's now also dropping behind on the
clock
now nihal probably is best advised to
cover the E4 square instead he goes Rook
C1 there's that before move but Anvil's
not really threatening anything because
B takes A3 might run into Rook takes C3
although there is Bishop B4 in that
position what a crazy end game we have
here nihal with a lot to calculate in
this position
for sure diet crazy line would be
something like oh quality C3 and Rook A3
you take here on C3 but then you go King
C1 and the bishop is trapped and there's
no Rook B8 as again the London Bishop is
covering that square what a line I mean
we might have to show that um on the
board Bishop A6 B takes A3 Rook takes C3
Bishop B4 looks like black has
insurmountable threats and you sack the
other Rook on A3 the point is that black
can only take one Rook at a time if we
rewind two moves Benjamin just to show
Bishop takes A3 gives up the bishop on
B3 and if you take the C3 Rook with the
Knight then white still takes on B3 and
there is no effective Discovery how hard
is that to see though and nihal is still
thinking you know that he senses that
there's something but he's got to find
that something and he goes for a
different approach Bishop to D3
he might still see that though
I think he sees that variation but now
mvl has a time to go let's say Pawn to
A5 slowly but surely creep up on the
queen side white still has a tough time
five and step and now maybe Knight F3 to
E5
yeah
stopping E4 yeah exactly and maybe in
some positions F4 blasting and cracking
open the center could be a nice asset
now the clock time becoming a deciding
factor 30 seconds for a knee-haul
position remains super super complicated
but was E4 actually a threat as there
will always be Bishop G5 check so it
feels like this weakens the bike
position Knight of three Now by nihal
excellent move oh wait was there takes
could he have just gone down that line
he could have and I think he didn't see
that Rook takes C3 and Rook takes A3
was winning but he missed it takes A3
what's going on here check now this
apron is going to be extremely dangerous
94 trade the Rooks and with only one
Rook white might not have enough
resources to stop that Apon from
promoting he goes instead Rook C7
keeping attention I still feel like from
a practical perspective it's much easier
to blunder with white but Knight D3 is
an excellent move exposing an attack on
The Rook where is it gonna go
Rook C6 Bishop B5 is possible
is losing valuable time rookie seven but
the Rook takes three that's the game
game finds it
and the bishop on B3 hangs MBL loses a
minor piece drops back to C4 and it's
over
well what a game yeah really cites
really chances for both sides it felt
like MPL had the better chance but
eventually he blundered in a Time
scramble that was a really confusing
game I think everybody was confused and
in such games from a human perspective
the goal is to blunder less than your
opponent right or the mistake you're
gonna commit mistakes because it's
impossible not to the goal is not to
commit any huge game deciding blunders
and mvl was the first to Flinch there
big big win for nehal and we've got one
more game until the halftime break
another crazy opening there's Knight on
D5 Knight on D4 okay not anymore
and a knight on G6 which usually only
ends up there in Fisher random but it
went from E7 to that square B5 nehal
expanding on the queen side maybe you
can go A5 threading to attract the
bishop with A4 and white has to play
Move Like C3 here I guess I strongly
dislike the way mvl has handled this
opening now Neal has the bishop pair
I thought maybe D5 could have been
considered by black now mvl can strike
first with D4 feels like black has
solved all of his opening problems and
then some
exactly a D4 looks like a nice move
striking in the center first let's see
what Neil's going to do there maybe D6
H4 by mvl wow I did not see demo coming
now do you follow the rule and meet a
flank move with a central strike that's
exactly what nihal does D5 is an
excellent Counter-Strike and we're gonna
get more tactics here right out of the
opening
I love that move D5 H5 can just be met
with Knight F4 Knight D3 so check the
threat the opponent E4 is under attack
MPL takes right away but maybe now E4 is
a nice intermezzo
E4 Knight D4 then you recapture on D5
but I think you're right C takes D5 does
run into H5
and that seems like a nasty move you
might have to part ways with your e-pawn
instantly
and there's nothing for black you can
take the Knight but white just takes us
working A8 and there's nothing there's
nothing you could even play D takes E3
and
black might have to give that Knight
away on like G2 or something but When
the Smoke Clears white it's going to be
up upon the Raging initiative due to
that Queen placement and that nicely
centralized Knight 95. Queen takes A8 is
a difficult move to play from a human
standpoint because the king will be so
exposed in the ensuing position
exactly I think Pawn X E3 like you
called it is a much more human move you
attack the Knight why if white is able
to take the Knight they will be up two
pawns The Rook is also under attack and
in case black takes here you recapture
with the Queen the rook and Aid is still
under attack and white is also eyeing
that pawn on G7
and queen takes G7 Forks The Rook on h8
and the pawn on F7 of course there is
Rook f8 to guard both at the same time
but oh nihal was not expecting to
confront problems of this magnitude
given how well the first 10 moves went
for him
yeah he rushed there a little bit with
the move Pawn takes D5 instead of the
move E4 and answer E5 all of a sudden he
was in a world of trouble he does give
him the knight in G2 now if he'll takes
a rook A6 on case white takes here then
indeed there's the move for Cafe
defending of seven and The Rook believe
it or not I think Queen takes G7 is not
the right way to play I don't know what
the right move is here but spending a
Tempo going Pawn hunting might backfire
because as pretty as the Knight on E5
looks if the queen moves away from the
long diagonal you have to watch out for
Queen d8 up to D5 and another issue is
that White's King
is kind of stuck in the center I mean
you're not really gonna Castle kingside
here with your king side and shambles
is white ultimately going to pay the
price for his compromise King position
he does take on G7 and I'm so curious
what his follow-up is going to be Queen
D5 now a big threat
I don't know diet almost looks easier to
play with black the black king is
sitting pretty safe on it but why it's
gonna be one it's kind of stuck for the
moment queenside castles is not
available
great call by you Benjamin E4 opening up
the diagonal for the bishop on C1
another positive byproduct of this move
he's a couple moves away from
stabilizing right Bishop F4 Rook D1 he
is up two pawns but he's down below a
minute can nihal continue to stir up
complications and dwindle White's clock
down all the way to zero big moment here
for knee-haw he can lift his Rook to the
center rookie six Bishop F6 he can do
both he does do both but White's Bishop
can come out just in the nick of time
supporting the Knight
yeah Bishop 4 looks like a nice move
developing the bishop and defending the
Knight he goes F4 but that does weaken
the opponent E4 and that's why nihal
goes after it right away with the move
Bishop to B7 maybe just Bishop B3 give
up the pawn and activate your pieces
another great call watch out for Bishop
H4 you have to keep the Rook pegged to
H2 to defend the H4 Square now Rook D1
possible follow-up and it looks like
black skin might get caught on the
crossfire after all
yeah I love how MPL has navigated the
complications here Dania and not already
here is to go Rook 32 and after the
queen moves all of a sudden you can go
Queen side castles with the idea to go
rookie stone or maybe Rook d8 on a good
day
oh my gosh if Flags Bishop on F6 had
been on E7 there there would have been
ideas of bowden's mate or the queen
takes C3 and Bishop A3 but even that
wouldn't work because the Rook could
block on B2 now the clock situation
equalizing I don't see a move for nehal
how does he keep the fire burning I
think MPL not only has distinct has
extinguished the fire but lit his own
fire against Black's King Bishop C5
Forks pins the Rooks
yeah Bishop C5 pickups The Exchange Rook
D5 I guess you just take you can also
just and there we go Rook D5 can you
just take here or is there a trick for a
news
I think nehal just wants to take back
and try to use his Bishops to generate
activity against White's King he's also
prevented white from castling Queen side
as MBL establishes a stronghold on G7
near Hall has to continue chiseling away
at White ponds with B4 something like
that Bishop F5 is his choice
right now you cannot move the rook and
still hang Bishop to H4 so maybe you
have to move your King and King of an
axon where do you want us to check but I
think you just take and go Queen to you
want to block very well spotted 10
seconds for mvl but I feel like black is
running out of active ideas and he is
down in exchange and upon Rook G2 is
also a devastating threat we're going
down this line nihal has to keep the
Queens on the board but 97-0 it's a
threat though bringing the Rook into the
game and stopping Queen E5
Knight D7 check is a simplifying move
that would make it so much easier for
white to play I think nehal is running
out of moves here B4 B4 even soflikuni
suits threatening Queen C5 it's tougher
black to defend here
filigree Precision for mvl
which is always the queen trade King G2
it looks fine King G3 G3 Queen H1 though
and the C8 squares and he might pull out
a draw no wrong way two there goes the
king though the king is running King D4
King D4 Queen G1 still pursuing the king
two that's game over incredibly spotted
wow and mvl turns it around at the last
second he escapes the checks by running
into the center
and he manages to sneak through another
Victory wowza what a win for maxim
what a game those complications were
wild but Enfield was able to navigate
those a little bit better and he opens
up a four point lead
a four-point lead for maxim nihal has
struck back on a number of occasions he
seems to be doing well with white he
seems to be getting the kinds of
positions that he wants I mean nihal in
this game right he got that kind of
unorthodox interesting position but
ultimately mvl has been sharper in the
tactics he's been better at time
management and he spotted these one and
two movers with Incredible regularity
measurement
yeah I know for sure one of the things
nihal was hoping perhaps for at the
start of the match where the time screen
was but mvl is certainly on par and
maybe even better in the time scramble
so it's gonna be tough for nehal to make
a comeback I think Dania he has to cut
into that lead in the second half of the
three percent portion to at least give
himself a chance going into the bullet I
agree it might be unrealistic for him to
erase that entire four point lead
quickly but we will see if he can
dwindle that lead down to something
manageable going to the bullet you folks
are watching the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase nihal
sarin taking on mvl in a fascinating
match and we will see if nehal has what
it takes to come back in this match on
the other side of this short break
foreign
[Music]
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I've
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got
unjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're going to be folders now
so I can categorize my white black and
all tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how I use
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
trustable it's actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
[Music]
love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variants Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
win any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
thank you
[Music]
foreign
is no stranger to incredible speed Chess
Championship performances he's got the
experience he's got the strength and he
has got the skill this year as he leads
nihal sarin by Four Points here in the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski
Grandmaster Benjamin Buck chopping it up
for you today Benjamin mvl needs no
introduction anybody with more than a
nodding acquaintance with the Chess
World Has Not only heard that name
they've heard all three names and they
know how good mvl has the capacity to be
exactly so let's have a look at his
speed Chess Championship resume MPL has
played in a lot of quarterfinals in the
SEC in 2017 he lost to grishek in 2018
he lost to karnakamura in 2019 he lost
the Wesley so but in 2020 and in 2022 he
won over Lavon aronian and Wesley Seoul
and these are his quarterfinal
appearances that means in all of these
years he did win uh his first matches to
reach the quarterfinals and the people
that he lost to there's no shame to
losing to any of them and this year it
feels like he has demonstrated Superior
form
uh to all of the years past he is in the
kind of form Benjamin that he was in
when he won the 21 World Blitz Champion
championship
yeah I know for sure when we talk about
the SEC there are two clear favorites
it's always going to be Hikaru and
Magnus but mvl is capable of scoring an
upset against these two he's in great
shape so far against nihal and I really
like how he has adjusted we saw him
struggling earlier in the match he lost
those two black games but he's really
right at the ship
he has indeed and he is one of the only
players to have defeated Magnus Carlson
in a speed Chess Championship Match knee
Hall has his work cut out for him and a
London system
as we resume the action 25 more minutes
folks of three plus one and then we will
have half an hour of bullet and of
course that is the Hall's best time
control but the comeback has to start
here
exactly and I think it would be great
for nihal to cut into mvl's lead a
little bit I'm a little bit surprised
that MPL makes the moves D5 and G6 again
again this bishop G7 is often just
biting on the Coronet as was looking at
the D4 pawn queen B6 attacking the pawn
on B2 but niho just defends it with
Queen to C1 as a grudenfield player mvl
has to be thinking about preparing C5 I
thought he could have maybe gotten away
with playing that move instantly and
that ship has sailed nihal doesn't give
him another opportunity play C5 himself
Queen is likely going to drop back no it
goes forward to A5 we've had this
structure a lot uh in in various
different types of positions
exactly and also nihal has excelled in
those games so let's see how mvl will
treat this one this time around G4 we've
seen also then move by Neil the bishop
is forced to go back to E6 and it's
making it more difficult to like to ever
get that E5 push in maybe now mvl can
trade we saw how earlier on he got his
pieces restricted so I think it would be
good idea for him to get some trades in
for sure and Knight takes C5 is one of
those trades then he can follow up with
Knight to E4 maybe and get more minor
pieces off the board the Queen trade
opens up the B file and we've already
seen several games where nihal was able
to effectively orchestrate big pressure
on that B7 Pawn
right so I like the fact that MPL trades
a knight on D5 like you said I think
it's quite risky to trade the Queens on
C3 I like 97 much better I think nihal
will keep the we the bishop on the board
here with a move like Bishop to G3 can
mvl consider a sec there with like
Knight xc5 you trade of the Queens maybe
you can take him B2 afterwards I don't
know I I'm a little bit skeptical about
that one but it's a possibility
it's interesting given that mvl holds a
sizable lead I feel like he'll probably
mitigate his risk
but before we get to that point nihal
has to decide whether he trades Bishops
and he does Bishops trade on G7 Rook fc1
now Enfield could drop his Queen back
right he doesn't have to keep his Queen
on A5 forever and he does Queen C7 he's
got several different plans here he can
play F6 Bishop F7 and E5 we've seen this
plan in action before he can also try to
open up the queen side with B6 I think
nihal is setting himself up for that
scenario by solidifying the C5 Pawn but
we are going to get some trades here H5
lost and move by mvl opening up the king
said the queen of C7 is eyeing that
square on H2 so mvl is planning for H6
G4 followed by Rook 2 h8 so nehal goes
Kenny G2 perhaps not after a trade and
Rook h8 you can go rock H1 and after
takes you can still recapture with the
queen you can also go F4 but that's
gonna weaken more squares on the king
side yeah that's gonna hurt positionally
great whole board awareness there by Max
seem to open up the king side now he
gets his Knight into the action nihal
trying to restrict it with F3
it still is a move I guess they're still
going to be Rook to H1 you can take
recapture the queen it feels like black
should be better here but I don't see an
immediate way to break through and also
Diane look at the clock all of a sudden
mvl is down almost a minute
yeah he's got all these tempting options
but that can actually backfire in you
know the lower time control games as you
try to puzzle out in this case which
file do you want to operate on after
rookie J Rook H1 you can play down the a
file or down the H file but that
involves giving away control of the
other file whichever file you're not
playing on you have to give away but
it's a moot point now because Knight F1
is a different way of protecting the H2
Square knee Hall trying to keep all of
his heavy pieces on the queen side
right so let's see what MPL is going to
do here perhaps he can trade but it
feels like white can then try to take
advantage of the open a fall maybe like
Queen A5 at the right moment he can also
keep his work on the board maybe Rook
ae8 combine it with Bishop C8 and all of
a sudden E5 would bring all of Black's
pieces to life yeah nobody canceled that
E5 plan he does something similar he
plays Rook a to B8 so clearly he's not
preparing E5 he is preparing B6 so mvl
trying to accentuate uh his Superior
pieces I think his pieces are somewhat
more active but nihal doing a great job
of keeping him at Bay 24 seconds for
Maxime that might become a problem
pretty soon
or Rook H7 a crafty little move by MPL
but nihal Queen ewanta G3 just in time
stopping Rook H2 and mvl once again
keeps the Queens on the board with Queen
C8 I think the crap wait can he say like
94. I was gonna point this idea out
earlier I think he's trying to set up
Bishop takes G4 or even Knight takes G4
and nihal might have to situate his
Queen on E5 in order to pin that Knight
and if Black's King is forced to the
eighth rank near Hall can double on the
a file he does that here and there's
that sack and here we go
right but what is the idea so it takes
94. takes on G4 but that doesn't create
a single threat Rook A8 wait isn't that
just game over
Rook A8 Rook takes h8 and either you
lose the Rook or you lose the Knight and
mvl gets burned for his time management
in this game
yeah root fix h8 and you'll lose
material and there we see nihal cuts
down the lead to three points well that
was a slightly anti-climactic finale to
that game mvl delayed the Sacrifice by
one extra move and that gave nihal the
chance to double Rooks and deliver the
victory with that devastating skewer on
A8 Big Win there it felt like that game
was also at some point going in mvl's
favor but Superior time management by
nihal and he needs more where that came
from
exactly if nihal keeps playing quickly
he will get his chance in this match I
think we've seen way too many games
where nihal dropped down on time and
even if he had better positions and we
all still found ways to turn his ones
around here we see mvl groom for a very
aggressive H4 H5 push but maybe nihal
just drops an eye back and what have you
achieved with this Palm push
yeah this also started out as a real
Lopez but now it resembles uh some sort
of souped-up for Knights defense and
white would really kill to have a Pawn
on see-through right now you would love
to place a D3 D4 in order to cut off
Black's influence in the center but as
it stands I like the way that nihal has
positioned his pieces mvl's still trying
to play on the king side there with
Knight H4 he does give up the D4 square
instead the hole goes to the side Knight
A5 is a very thematic move in these
types of positions to eliminate the
all-important light squared Bishop again
I'm not a fan of the way that mvl has
responded to nihal's Knight G7 system
E6 and for black is going to be a lot
easier now to break with the move D5
Bishop E3 but I can trade the question
is where is Castle you can go kingside
Castle I think the king should be
sitting pretty safe over there you can
go queenside Castle after you played
with A6 but White's got that half open
file so that could perhaps be a little
bit risky
near Hall maintains his Bishop pair I
liked I like the idea of playing Queen
D7 but not necessarily to prepare
queenside Castle but rather to build
that battery and in some situations you
have Bishop G4
but Queen G3 by mvl Rook G8 is a very
committal move that means that black has
to either stay in the center or Castle
Queen side and I actually think we will
see Queen side castles because that is
the Lesser evil Benjamin especially if
white opens up the center with F4 or D4
Knight A2 where is he going
Bishop has to go back to B6 but now you
weaken the black pawn structure C4
gaining more space the knights headed
back to C3 and all of a sudden White's
got a pretty nice grip here queenside
Castle is really unappealing black I
thought had to organize counter play on
the other side of the board with G7 G5
he had a chance to open the G file and
Garner serious play against White's King
now it's mvl's turn to play on the king
side F4 is another excellent move and
with his previous move C4 Benjamin he
clamped down on the D5 Square so later
on the knight from A2 it's going to make
its presence felt especially if it moves
into D5
right knee-hole solidifying his Center
here with F6 also making sure that F5
can be met with Bishop F7 Queen E3 by
mvl he switches his attention to the
queen side hitting the spawn over here
94 by nihal threatening a fork on C2 so
let's see what mvl is going to do maybe
a rook F2 to stop that he ignores he
ignores it I think that's a great sack
practically nicely to Queen takes B6 and
nehals Rooks in that resulting position
are terrible he doesn't have any way of
opening the position up I'm I'd be
shocked if nehal actually accepts that
sacrifice
right but if you don't accept this okay
and there we go
great for mvl Rook takes a one also
night night B5 is a serious problem in
that position and now he'll drop the
queen back I think to E3 or F2
yeah Queen E3 it's on the board B5 now
is a serious idea wait maybe you can
take another quick screen B6 that picks
the B4 Pawn that was a pawn but he
doesn't do it keeps the position closed
and now the Knight sinking its teeth
into that beautiful Outpost if black
plays Bishop F7 And Trades it then it'll
be the other night's turn to jump into
D5 black can't keep all of the weak
squares protected with a single minor
piece
exactly and maybe at the right moment
MPL can consider the move Knight D5
after a trade takes the queen of the
move and then Queen H3 check will be
pretty unpleasant so a tough position
here for nihal who's also a little bit
down on the clock
this looks
terrifying for black and the position is
closed so black will have to defend for
many many more moves
and he's also down now to a minute on
the clock I feel like MBL is close to
taking this game as well
right the king really doesn't have a
safe place to hide like where do you go
it doesn't really sit safe on the queen
side King C7 again it could be met with
a move like 95 or maybe a rook C1
setting up all of those ideas Niha 45
seconds on the clock he has to be
extremely careful here
there's just no moves
yeah like no active ideas I don't see it
either what MPL could also do okay
Bishop 7 is played maybe 95 there we go
Bishop takes I guess you take it to the
e-pawn and there's still Queen C7 but
rookie eight
okay obviously the position is not going
to win itself you eventually I think
have to open up the queen side and open
an Avenue for your Rook if you're mvl so
you could consider the move B5 you could
consider Rook to C1 and C5 he goes for
it I think that's an excellent idea and
I think nihal's position is continuing
to crumble here especially if white can
find a good opportunity to push C5
Queen A7 also looks sick
and not only the position is a problem
here for Neil also the clock he's down
to 23 seconds maybe Queen A7 here
threatening not to slide in just yet but
maybe setting up B5 you go to C5
blasting open the position
and nihal with 20 seconds to figure out
this crazy complications Queen takes D5
C6 is interesting but then black can
force the queen trade with Queen to D4
and you have to be careful about that if
you're white I would play Queen D4 here
he takes on D6 threatening Queen D4 MBL
needs a prophylactic move here to stop
the queen trade which would cause
White's initiative to fizzle out move
your king away instead he goes Queen F3
threatening the pawn how do you defend
it
is made
oh wow man look at that
Checkmate wow what a shocker but
actually one move before the end niho
was actually doing fine had he found
Rook to E6 the idea is that if you take
a B7 there's Queen B6 force and queen
trade
but that was such a difficult move
especially after what seemed like a
lifetime of Defending that nasty
position and another win for mvl it is
back up to that pesky four point lead
every time it seems like nihal is
getting some momentum mvl comes back
with an excellent game
yeah four points is a lot like three
points like two points are still very
doable because you win one game and then
all of a sudden you only need one more
three is still tricky but also still
doable but four is a lot I am it is a
lot especially the way that mvl is
playing he's not giving away a single
easy game even the games that Newhall is
winning they're coming down to the wire
they're coming down to individual
tactics and then mvl immediately strikes
back with a victory man this is gonna be
a very very tough road ahead for
knee-haul we've got this position again
this London system with blacks control
over the center this time at VL he's
he's shown a proclivity for this move B5
in various positions
exactly and Diane there's probably still
two more games left in the three plus
one portion I think nihal at least has
to try to close down to three points
absolutely
three preparing to C4 push the question
is always is black gonna go E4 here we
have to move C4 by nihal opening of the
queen side B4 interesting Movement by
mvl to gain more space on the queen side
and Garner the C3 Square which could in
the future serve as an outpost for his
Knight and that's not as remote of a
possibility as it appears you know if I
play C5 for instance which I would not
advise black and play Knight DB5 and
you're already threatening to jump into
C3 with great effect how does nihal
resolve the tension on the queen side
does he keep the tension of the move
like Queen C2 does he take one of
Black's pawns what appeals to you here
I think he is gonna uh preserve the pr
the detention when it move like Queen C2
however black has a move like Bishop 5
and you're gonna have to move the queen
to B2 where it's sitting fine aha he
does take on E5 and he takes on D5 but
maybe now Knight takes D5 and Knight C3
Diane mvl goes for it and Knight C4 by
nihal so Knight C3 is a tempting move
but is the threat stronger than this
execution do you want to keep that move
in your pocket instead
no and there we have it okay well he
sack on something takes
but what is the follow-up
I don't know okay we see this is 85. uh
he just play additional sacrifice
I kind of like it I mean he's got one
Pawn for the moment upon a C3 is
terribly weaked upon a C6 this week and
how does mvl stop nihal from playing
Queen C2 Queen takes E3 then Neil would
get a second pawn and all of a sudden
there are ideas like Bishop C4
also very instructive if black moves the
night away from D6 there's Knight takes
C6 forking the queen in the rook and
then taking the E7 Queen with checks so
mvl has to burn a Tempo to defend that
pawn queen C2 an excellent follow-up
targeting the C3 Pawn that was a really
instructive exchange sacrifice but nehal
has to follow it up with another
accurate sequence opening up the bishop
mvl fights fire with fire
see if I could remove my Enfield I guess
nihal should take the pawn I don't see
any a tactic just yet maybe like Knight
F7 putting more pressure on the Knight
on E5 Neo could respond here with Bishop
C4 pinning the Knight and F7
and that will likely be met with Bishop
to D5 interposing the pen with Black's
own bishop and the battle revolves
around that Knight on E5 can't nehal
keep that Knight afloat
right so let's have a look I think
Bishop C4 looks pretty logical to me for
the moment black is threatening to take
on a three super C4 hitting the Knight I
guess Bishop D5 as you mentioned is
forced here and what does nihal do here
E4 aha E4 forcing the bishop trade on
his own terms because the queen will
recapture on C4 the Knight on F7 will be
pinned and there will be the threat of a
fork on C6 and VL could respond calmly
though with something like rook ac-8 and
the game continues
right so let's see what he's gonna do
this looks unpleasant for black panther
to take after take Stakes as this pin is
very difficult to get out of maybe you
can take an E4 but they look so risky
Dania it's just not a move you consider
Bishop takes E4 my goodness be still my
Beating Heart Bishop takes F7 Queen
takes F7 and the undefended Queen on C3
is what makes this possible and feel
sees it the fact that he's pausing here
tells me that he sees alternatives to
Bishop takes C4 he might also be
thinking about taking 95 and he's done
it he's found it and that is the only
way to preserve objective Dynamic
equality it's weird to talk about
equality here but both sides with
excellent chances here
eyes in his veins he takes us upon an E4
it looked impossible but MPL has
perfectly navigated the complications
rookie one Bishop D5 wow and there's no
Discovery with the Knight as it's
actually pinned what is going on here it
seems like someone vomited in the center
it's just like pins everywhere Black's
Queen is is pinned White's Queen is
pinned there's a discovery I don't think
you can move the knight from E5 Knight
takes G6 I simply think black will play
H takes G6 and that Queen on C3 is
what's really really hurting white
there's a trade Queen C4 Queen B7
another accurate move mvl is on fire
but mvl just recaptures and is doing
completely fine all of a sudden mvl's up
half a minute on the clock so maybe he
can even extend his lead here a little
bit that always seems to happen no
matter how complicated the position
Maxime has kept that late on the clock
but I really like that move by nihal a
very mature decision keeping pieces on
the board but is there Rook D1 and
doesn't the trait of Rooks favor black
queen D5 can be Queen B4 oh Queen Force
the queen trade
oh my gosh
if mvl wins this game nihal is gonna
face a tough top deficit
he's finding every move in the critical
position
okay one you still cannot avoid the
queen trade and you take the penalty too
raw K1
speaking of ice in his veins will he
find yet another actor and what he does
Rook A3
rookie three maybe you take like 92 but
it looks terrible
man the fact of the matter is that white
can't move the queen away in another
accurate move this is a masterpiece by
Maxime tactically positionally
technically and white is borderline no
white is just lost here
yeah white sauce white cannot escape the
queen trade in the end game looks
completely losing so what do you even do
here like trade a 92 but Bishop C3 is
coming in
this game what are you doing this match
he takes them before which Pawn does MBL
take with the c pawn bishop C3
Rook a three and B3 this is over okay
Four Knights Rook takes a four simply
he's up in exchange and he's got the
passer which is gonna decide the game
Bishop exactly don't blunder the pawn
oh yeah don't do that go
a five maybe hit the Knight okay 18
seconds
to be careful
Bishop should be five
Knight B3 Bishop takes E3 B3 you find
this at the pawn of motion this should
be the game G3
I like rookie too as well and that's
another game for MVR who opens up a five
point lead I am that wasn't the
flashiest game of the match but from a
purely scientific objective perspective
that might have been mbl's best game
that was a classical level game the way
that he navigated those tactical
complications against someone of nihal's
caliber this is what niho is supposed to
do mvl stole his Thunder and he is up by
five with five and a half to go in the
three minute portion this is likely to
be the last game given how long these
games have taken a win would go a long
way toward filling the hall with at
least a little bit of confidence going
into the bullet but you can kind of read
it in his body language he is not happy
with the way this match is going and can
you blame him
you cannot blame him at all he needs at
least he should not lose this game if
you lose this game he goes down six
going into the ball portion
mathematically he still has a chance
there but MVR would have to lose every
single game but like I said Diana that
game was extremely impressive by MPL
Bishop C4 was a star move
danville's form has been ridiculous now
we have an end game here they followed a
topical theoretical line for a long time
that Knight dropped back to D6 now who
do you think is pressing here in this
end game or is it dead equal
I think it should be around even but if
anything white has a tiny tiny Edge the
pawns on C7 and A7 are a little bit weak
also for the moment Black's Bishop pair
isn't too too scary I think move like
Bishop before looks quite nice to
neutralize the bishop a bit 93 I think
here Black's doing absolutely fine after
like before I think mvl kind of
consciously choosing a lower risk line
because I don't think white is risking
here his position is too healthy the
game will likely end on a draw and
that's more than fine for maxim
solidifying that five-point lead he
could not ask for more but he is still
trying Knight H4 and Knight F5 I feel
like Black's position practically a
little bit unpleasant here
yeah not for sure despondent if I have
still a little bit weak you can go a
four-do to trade it off and give white
an isolated Pawn on B3 so I do trust
nihal to hold the draw here but I think
like you said it makes it auto Bishop
fade the Bishops stay on the board black
has potential to be better here
absolutely if you can get A4 and and
isolate that pawn on B3 Maxine playing
A4 himself but speaking of the weakness
on B3 that is a very committal move that
is a sign that Maxim doesn't like what's
happening on the queen side
right and does Neil I have a move like
Knight C4 here if you think of the
Knight you leave the Knight on F5
hanging on the bottom B3 is very
difficult to defend you might have taken
the Palm but then black takes the bishop
on B2 and this could be a crucial game
for nehal to get back in the match and
give himself some confidence going into
the bullet I think C5 is the next best
thing here though he advances the pawn
potentially we'll move it up to C4 and
the fact that the Rook on B7 is x-raying
the bishop on B2 that's a big deal
because white would love to play a move
like Rook a to C1 but here that would
drop a pawn due to the prosaic tactic
Knight takes A4 so mvl is a little bit
hamstrung by the positional and tactical
weaknesses in his position maybe bishop
C3 uh should be considered here just
moving the bishop out of the line of
fire of The Rook on B7 instead he takes
a more concrete approach with Knight to
D6 circling back maybe to C4 with his
Knight
right but if you go 94 you always have
to be careful of this motivation to see
two hitting the rook and the pawn on B3
so I really think he should have just
traded off the visual on G6 he doesn't
have an edge there but just steer the
game towards the draw go into the bullet
with a five point lead but now this game
still could go nihal's way
most certainly and now Bishop takes D6
or Rook D7
both of those moves should be considered
Bishop takes D6 Rook takes D6 you'd love
to play Knight C8 uh with a minor
problem that blunders made in one but
it's clear that Black's best chance is
to directly assault that pawn on B3
yeah Rook D7 go move I think if you're
Niha you definitely have to go for this
keep winning chances Knight B5 by mvl
maybe you can trade all the white just
recapture C2 is still guarded I think
for the moment mvl is still fine but
nehal has to try to go for a win here as
they would go a long way for his chances
in the bullet and again I'm a broken
record but the time management for
Maxima has been Exquisite in the three
minute portion again he's up 40 seconds
he's all no matter what the position
actually is even if he's under pressure
on the board he's always putting
pressure on the clock and that has been
so effective it's been one of the many
components that has given him this
five-point lead but look at nehal C4
excellent tactical Vision Knight takes
C4 he wants to trade Knights and stick
his Bishop on C2 and you called a
Benjamin Bishop C2 is going to make an
appearance
yeah C4 great move by Neil if you think
of the point you hang the pawn on A4 so
probably you have to think of the knife
then black takes and goes Bishop to C2
hitting the Rook yeah and upon A4 there
is still Rook day one but then black has
Rook C8 and how do you defend the policy
for Bishop D4 wait nehal just sex and
then it goes back to the knights he's
three Bishop B4 Knight D5 look at mvl on
corking move after moving he is up a
piece and he is stopping promotion what
is nihal's follow-up in this position I
think he should probably make a slow
move like Rook to C8 and try to apply
pressure on the C3 Knight there's 40
seconds left in the match this is likely
to be the last game
and he found that that's why nihal
played H6 it's not necessarily to
prevent Rook d8 mate it's so that his
King can escape to H7 if the Knight
delivers a check on E7 this is high
degree of complication here as mvl Falls
below a minute now what does white do
the ball in his court he needs to
eliminate the pawn on B2 that is much
easier said than done I think White's
playing off the back foot here
yeah perhaps you can go Rook D2 there
will be Queen B1 take Stakes you're
taking although I get three minor piece
there that's a lot for the Rook
it is
H3 maybe just throw the ball back in
black but then maybe Rook see it in the
line also works for black
I don't like this for MBL practically
this is so difficult but Rook D2
excellent move Bishop A3 guarding the
pawn and then what Bishop A3 I think is
the best practical chance
maybe H3 then and what is Blackstar yes
you can go B1 okay rookie eight I guess
you just go H3 Bishop B3 fine as well
and there's no tactic there's still no
tactic for black yeah now black has a
drone black and black can take C3 and
promote and I think with four seconds on
the clock he doesn't see an alternative
he has to make the draw here one second
zero move
oh he disconnected what an unfortunate
moment for Neo who goes down six points
going into the bullet the worst moment
for disconnection it was precisely when
he dropped below 10 seconds that his
camera froze his internet goes down and
that is exactly the one thing that he
did not need as he falls below six
points that is a huge lead for maxim
vashilograph who wins both of the first
segments with the same score six points
two three for a total of 12 to 6
Benjamin
mathematically it's already looking
extremely difficult for nihal he's six
he's down six points going into the
bullet there are 30 minutes left eye and
those bully games can easily take five
minutes so he's gonna have to win pretty
much every game now
but what you said is important
mathematically possible it's a six point
lead we've seen The Comebacks of that
scale in the SCC before this isn't a 10
point lead this is not unprecedented and
mvl first of all we hope that he fixes
his internet uh ASAP and I think he's
not giving up hope he's going to keep
trying and uh before we go on our break
and set the players up for our final
segment we wanted to take a moment to
thank ag1 a new partner of the speed
Chess Championship ag1 is your daily
support of key Health functions for
mental performance to energy and the
immune system it's the one product that
does the work of many to find out more
visit
drinkag1.com chess or use x Glam ag1 in
the chat we think ag1 for sponsoring the
SCC and we thank the players for giving
us an excellent two and a half hours of
action mvl is on top he holds a six
point lead and we will have more speed
Chess Championship action with the final
bullet segment but first we're gonna set
the players up with a short break we're
gonna check on nihal's internet and
we'll be back with more SEC action on
the other side of this break
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the ebal graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
king of crushing this giant is a living
Siege Tower usually found in groups
goblins are fond of sharp pointy objects
and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare lay them all on
chess.com
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
holds a six-point lead coming into the
final bullet segment of this speed Chess
Championship Match presented by coinbase
nihal sarin has his back against the
wall Grandmaster Benjamin Buck he needs
a miracle let's not mince our words he
needs to run the table in these next 30
minutes
yeah he needs a big big comic here Diane
needs to win games he needs to win a lot
of them and he needs to win them fast
bullet games even in the the OnePlus One
portion can take up to five minutes
sometimes so he needs to cut into that
win as quickly as possible Diane and
feels having a strong run but this is
not the first time he's having a strong
run
well his 2020 run is his best of the SCC
thus far he defeated none other than the
whole star and in round one with a
convincing performance five-point
Victory then he beat Lavon aronian by
two points then he defeated Magnus
Carlson yes he defeated Magnus Carlson
in the SEC something that very very few
people have done I think only Hikaru
Nakamura has managed that feed but then
losing two none other than Hikaru in the
final so Maxime no stranger to amazing
SCC runs but his job is not done because
nihal is a bullet wizard I would go so
far as to say that Newhall often does
the heavy lifting in his SCC victories
in the bullet segment so we need more
speed more opening Acumen more tactical
foresight by mvl he needs more of the
same and he needs to keep his legs
churning okay we are underway 30 minutes
of bullet Ken nihal pull out the miracle
come back let's get to the games
I like the opening here for nehal he's
up he's a little bit better given the
fact that he's got the bishop pair and
black spawn structure is slightly
weakened that being said MVR has pretty
good piece play here but yeah he needs a
lot of wins and uh I'm curious MPL
normally is not the type of guy to run
the clock down but do you think we'll
see him do that here
um I think we might I think it's gonna
depend on how the first few games are
going the first game is going in mvl's
favor again and you all played too
quickly he has over a minute on his
clock and already a terrible position
H6 setting up Knight G5 this looks
terrible actually 563.
and Rook C2 as well this looks terrible
for white if MPL wins this game diet is
it it's still mathematically not over
but it's starting to enter that realm I
just feel like in nihal such a confident
player but the way that he's playing
here it seems like he's losing faith in
in his ability to make a comeback and
this first game is is not the new Hall
that we're used to he's playing
passively all of his pieces are in the
back rank but not taking anything away
from mvl who's in complete control of it
seems every game and he's already struck
with a victory in the first bullet game
that wasn't even close I mean that was
wire to wire and nihal is nehal is on
tilt
yeah there was a tough loss for Niha mvl
opened up a seven point lead you know we
blinked her eyes and before we knew it
it was over what a great game by mvl now
nihal he needs some wins quickly
he does and we've transposed into
akarokan he's played one A6 kind of
Hikaru style Then followed up with C6
and D5 so it's not as bad of an opening
as I think people think it is because
it's hard to punish if black follows up
by playing a Karo Khan setup
there should be yeah A6 A6 isn't that
bad very often it's quite a useful movie
karudo took it one step further and
played the movie A5 in his first magic
Museum like that not only wastes a move
but it also weakens your position
that's exactly right
but uh Hikaru it seems can pull a win
out of any position out of any match
situation and nehal needs a little bit
of Hikaru magic right now the problem
with the game like this is that it's
very likely to take a bunch of time off
the match clock we have this sort of
closed end game and both players I mean
they've got over 50 minutes on their
clock so I don't think that this bullet
segment is going to be decided by time
scrambles
yeah this is a typical knee-hole
position he's a little bit better and I
can go A5 and B4 but it's gonna be
difficult to break through at the right
moment in the meantime I can say with
king of three and if you go before white
just takes twice G4 gray move by MPL
creating some counter play on the king
side yeah he's taking the standing up
and Rook H3 sets up H5 now he might not
want to play H5 too quickly because the
king is going to be exposed to frontal
checks with Rook G8 instead he kind of
goes for Passive defense with Rook H2
I feel like you might have a fortress
but does Neil have this idea of getting
his King all the way to B3
now A4 stops it all and there's no way
to break through you can I mean you can
apply pressure to pawn B2 there's
nothing else you're gonna Rook H5 maybe
piece of gray move by ml the creating
counter playing the queen side he's
playing for a win mvl is now playing for
when rugby two Rook takes B3 and the A5
Pawn is going to be a serious weakness I
love everything about the way that
Maxime is playing this
yeah Ruby took remov you just take King
G5 but King G5 how do you stop the king
from coming in you're gonna have to go
Rook C8 to C4 instead he goes Rook B5
liquidating pawns on the queen side now
it looks like a draw again but King G5
still and it's still unpleasant for
black
and the a pawn can push forward as well
to deflect Black's Rook away from F3
okay okay eight by seven that's another
game for mvl that that's another game
is that already the match oh no
he didn't have to do his ass he didn't
but how about some Pizzazz some oomph to
seal off this game the D3 Pawn there's
nothing black would rather do than to
take his own Pawn
and MPL wins another game and opens up
with eight point lead clever decision
there for nihal just to resign and get
another game going
I'm speechless this is a complete
drubbing at this point this is
reminiscent of magnus's performance in
the bullet against nepo at some point
the match starts
you know starts start starts to pull
away and you know it's so hard to
motivate yourself if your knee-haul to
continue playing and to continue
fighting but he has to do it
a little bit surprised by enfield's
opening Choice normally he doesn't go
into the Pierce defense usually he meets
Knight C3 with D5 stopping the E4 push
that being said he's not doing too bad
here you can go let's say queen A4 987
and queen side castle and that's what
he's going for right now
he can Castle in this position he can
establish a knight on D5 actually by
keeping his King in the center he opens
up the door for something like Knight C3
which is a very typical tactic in some
of these positions so he actually might
choose to play Rook B8 and keep his King
in the center where I think it's
relatively safe yeah he's playing A5 I
think he's gonna attack on the queen
side rather than Castle to the queen
side
yeah Queen C6 also knows what he wants
to go A4 A3 Corva that see through
square and then jump in with his Knight
this king is sitting perfectly safe
behind this wall of Bones A3 and Knight
C3 boo
this is uh getting ugly again Knight C3
King A8 what now though but yeah I don't
see a breakthrough maybe just 95 you
know like ah
23.3 he blundered a piece and a rookie
two rookie two but you you hang the
knights that's unfortunate
Donya you're a very experienced bullet
player if MPL ends up in a losing
position do you think he should milk out
the clock or playing to keep his rhythm
um milk well milk out the clock at this
point with 23 minutes left in the match
there might not be mathematically enough
time uh to play seven games so I would
say yeah take a minute take two minutes
off the match clock because you're not
like dead yet okay but that's very great
Surprise by that
is
maybe he feels like he's gonna win
anyway or or again he might not want to
hurt his rhythm but here's the thing and
I'm not trying to be disingenuous I'm
not trying to to speak untruth you know
but okay it's currently what it's a
seven it's a seven point match and he
has seven points now if he wins two more
games suddenly the lead doesn't start to
feel as safe it feels completely safe
right now but all nihal needs is a
little bit of a streak to fill himself
up with confidence and nihal is the kind
of player who absolutely has the
capacity to start winning one game after
another
exactly and here we have a double edge
game on our hands why does it take on
the king's have a black can potentially
maybe wait Queen H3 hitting the rook in
the nine F3 how do you deal with that
Queen H3 looks like a great move forces
the Knight back away from F3 to prevent
white from doubling Rooks I think that's
an important move but why is he allowing
Rook G1
whoa Knight takes F2 but takes I don't
know
and there we have you can give up the
queen but that looks lost
there's no checks oh King C2 oh
or Knight T2 there we have it your best
move of Queen E3 that's all tells it all
it's just lost resigns Queen E6 Queen G5
take away the E7 square and this is
another game for mvl
what was Knight B6 I I just it feels
like nihal is leaving so many of these
points on the tables making moves that
strategy was to keep playing and just
get another game to keep his rhythm
yeah
another one an eight point lead with
what is it 21 minutes on the clock that
looks very tough to surround now at this
point with 10 more minutes off the
bullet match clock
this is starting to look like another
blowout
Kiana what a match by mvl he takes on D4
here right away maybe at five notes open
on the bishop but yeah he's been playing
great this entire match
he has indeed
Bishop up to D3
looks like another one of those London
system setups with black establishing a
nice Knight on e4
I like what Neil is doing here though C4
try to open up the center quickly I
guess Neil's only chance is to play
every game super quickly and try to win
with over a minute on the clock and
that's what he's trying to do right here
yeah
back to C3 F5
okay
could she forget side
and okay you can make
you can make a lot of moves on instant
but at some point you have to pause and
calculate for a little bit and that's
where nihal is going to lose a little
bit of time
an exchange Sacrifice by Maxime as he
tries to keep his Bishops alive he's
probably gonna involve his Queen via H4
instead he takes on T4 that opens up the
D file that probably actually helps
white after Queen to D2
yeah I don't like that move because now
you can no longer move the queen as you
hang the bishop with check and how do
you get out of the spinning takes on G2
maybe just Rook 81 yeah Rook 8 D1 Bishop
takes E4 and you can actually take on D4
with check still not over there as long
as black keeps the G2 Pawn he gives
himself some practical chances but you
could actually take on e4 and Bishop
takes F2 makes a lot of noise but after
King takes G2 there are no more
follow-up trucks I think nihal is going
to take this one
yeah let's see what he's going to The
Rook Dixie forward and the although I
mean the game is not over just yet
there's still work to be done you can
take on D4 going to a winning end game
with Bishop C6 you know the game game
goes on for now
okay seven activating The Rook
okay what do you do maybe like H6 and
Rook H4 work F6 and there's still some
work to be done
yeah H6 Rook D6 Maybe
Bishop back to F3 but Rook dd7 I think
sets up Unstoppable threats
yeah Route 87 is winning here for white
so let's see if mvl will milk at the
clock here I would be surprised as he
didn't do this earlier and right now his
position okay take check on Rook C7 or
Rook h8
or that yeah yeah okay mvl yeah
mm-hmm
right so do you think it's just him
being a gentleman he doesn't want to
milk out the clock or again you think he
just wants to keep the pace
I think he's just being a gentleman I
think he you know when he feels like the
position is hopeless as you said earlier
the lead is so big and he's so confident
in the SEC this year he doesn't feel
like it's even a remote possibility that
he allows anything resembling you know a
comeback especially now that almost half
of the match clock has elapsed and nihal
has not bit into this late at all
yeah Bishop B6 we have another
double-edged position with mvl going for
Queen side castles so let's see what
he's going to do maybe like Knight of
five attack the queen eventually this
bishop is going to develop
Ed I would take the Knight though I
would take the Knight
take it maybe 96 after totally
yeah also nice move
should be two
C5 to follow three and Bishop F5 and
he's okay now you have to move your
queen
yeah but Queen C6 and the Knight on B5
is stranded mvl he's still leading by a
very comfortable margin and uh Diane but
you know if he loses one game after
another he has to be a little bit
careful and perhaps then he should
consider milking the clock
definitely this is looking pretty dire
for black takes takes takes and Nissan
up a pawn and attacking with B4 this is
a losing position now for mvl and
finally it looks like nehal is knocking
on the door of two games in a row after
B4 Bing go
yeah I think for nihal it will be a big
boost towards confidence to get that
second win in a row in because he he's
won one oh no seven no
oh that's unbelievable
he never blunders like this never
and he's exasperated you can sense it
one mover
wow you don't make that all day it's not
over just yet the white skin on B2 is
exposed but I mean maybe niho should
consider resigning save himself sometime
this one is technically overest fruit
before can always block I think that
would be a consideration if this was a
three or a four point lead realistically
though I think he should just keep this
one going hope for some sort of a freak
tactic there's just nothing The Rook C1
great move to meet rookie two with Rook
C2 covers the check Bishop B6 will be
tried I think but Rook C3 Rook before
it's over before trading of the Rooks
yeah Queen D6 now this is going to be
another one for mvl
yes it is Rook B8 okay just resigns
lead once again and with 16 and a half
minutes diet it's starting to look
insurmountable
it is I think it is instrumental but now
16 minutes remaining and that is just a
dagger Benjamin you do everything right
you're winning with black you're about
to get to in a row and then Bang 97.
right I think had he won that game it's
of course very very tall but still some
chances but now I mean the match is just
practically over especially after such a
heartbreaking loss
indeed C4 we've got essentially the same
type of structure but with colors
reversed here as MBL closes the center
and will start to attack on the queen
side knee-hal Knight takes you okay yeah
just going all Full Tilt but that this
is nice I like it actually
maybe bishop 6 was better followed by H7
now MPL very quickly with B3 Diane this
is almost like a reverse Kings Indian
totally but somehow it seems like MBL is
garnering serious counter play on the
other side of the board Knight C4
and Bishop C6 opening up the B file
preparing Queen B7 and the threats
against White's King are suddenly very
serious
and you know in the meantime the
blacking can't just run King D7 you kill
this one over here but Queen B7 where
are the threats for white what are you
the queen
there is between but 93 and you lose the
light Square Bishop as well
or even it's gonna be another way
although then there might be B4 Yak King
C7 look at that Knight on C4 it's both
attacking B2 and defending the D6 Square
Black's King is safe yeah take another
Bishop that's just a one move or King C8
is over
yeah
indeed okay 96 threading Checkmate maybe
just a calm Bishop to D7
why not see something cool uh can be
what no but now he's giving up the piece
though he should be better I think MBL
blundered the Knight on A3
yeah King C2 all right maybe bishop D7
Bishop five still transfer MPL to save
this one by the way I want to point
something out as this game heads to its
conclusion there have been no draws in
this match yet this has been the first
SCC match with no draws I can't believe
that I'm even saying that but now that
you think about it there have been no
draws now that I say that probably this
game will end intro
but really there have been no draws
I can't believe I'm even saying that but
apparently so
that is insane like usually there's a
drawer too but yeah I can recall a
single draw either
incredible
but maybe this game will end in a draw
who knows maybe Angela can go Knight C8
to B6 to C4 it goes 96 instead but
rolling up the board he's not even in a
rush to play off five you can do it at
your convenience you're up a thousand
pawns it's actually still not that easy
with the pawn on A4 holding down the
Rook
should be three person they need a lot
of five
so that's where mvl's gonna go if he
goes to B3 then F5 will come in
uncontested
Rook A3
it would be hilarious if this game ended
in a draw
right I don't see how though I don't see
how but you know maybe some rear
Perpetual down the line yeah you never
know or some positional draw where white
plays E6 and black sex is night for it
and then why can't make progress I can
see that happening
[Music]
he won
nice maneuver
Allah he's giving up the pawn okay what
does he have in mind 96 by mvl
okay yeah Bishop C5 nice move blocking
the Rock
okay now it's dead winning even though
black has the light score blockade
eventually it's going to be surmounted
yeah Bishop C2 mvl keeping this game
going I mean he's still fighting on and
milking some time off the clock but he
resigns
he resigns and it's back down to what is
it
a uh seven point lead but with only 12
minutes on the match this one is in the
book still though always worth watching
the end of these matches we always get
some entertaining bullet games even when
we've got a blowout
all right okay so uh they enter that
same line again Diane they seem to be
working out pretty well for nehal
all right mvl got into a lot of trouble
in this game so I'm kind of yeah where's
the Improvement where's the Improvement
maybe I'll give you one here
but 94 is coming again
do you defend the B7 Pawn first though
do you play B6
all right B6 makes sense perhaps you
trade is that Bishop ended up being very
passive knee-hal taking a lot taking a
bit of time here all right so let's see
what mvl is going to do 94 again
perhaps
the good thing about inducing B6 is that
black can no longer play Knight B6
Knight C4 and um as long as that square
on C4 is unoccupied I think you called
it the threat of C4 I think would force
black to play Rook C4 he's allowed G5 he
walked right into that and C4
just looks winning D5 as we can see
three as well defended uh Queen B5 looks
great and he goes for it that move just
epitomizes mvl's form throughout this
match he's finding every one of these
important moves
yuck right and niho also an ID of six
isn't isn't very characteristic for him
usually he finds these tricky moves to
keep the game going but now he's just
handing mvl a great end game
yeah white is up a couple pawns the A7
Pawn is also likely to fall and that
Bishop on D5 such a monster it can also
supervise the progress of Rook A6 and
Rook takes G6 I think
that's a nice move you have to go Rook
d8 only moves in the game
uh and Rook takes G6 but there are some
pieces hanging after that though King
yeah where do you go
Rook F6 and you've got everything
defended and Rook F1
yep no you stay up a piece King H2 and
that's another game for mvl
wow eight points this is impressed back
and he's playing out of his mind today
the final 10 minutes of this excellent
match definitely
not a performance that nihal will
remember fondly this started out pretty
well I mean he was up he won the first
game he was up by a point things seem to
be going well for him but then he lost a
couple of those disappointing 50 50
games and mvl never looked back
exactly he started with a two to one
lead but he lost some games that he
actually maybe should have won and then
mvl just ran away with it
I mean obviously it's easy to Monday
Morning Quarterback but remember that
game where Newhall was in the driver's
seat with black then they got into that
opposite color Bishop position and
ultimately flagged I feel like that game
really impacted him and it gave mvl the
confidence that he needed to seize the
lead in the five minute portion and then
expand that lead in the 60 Minutes of
three plus one which honestly was one of
the most impressive stretches that I've
ever seen in the SEC it wasn't
necessarily an eye-popping score you
know 63 sounds pretty mundane but the
level of play demonstrated by mvl was
off the charts in this match Bishop E5
and night before at the end
yeah that's a tactic and MPL of course
spots it of course because the bishop
and you even another one there
this is going to be another win
yeah but also in some games after that
MPL didn't always play his best chess
but niologist didn't really catalyze on
any of the chances they were presented
to him
you know we're so used to newhall's
Excellence his tactical Excellence as we
see a bishop trade that the engine
didn't like there that any time he
performs at a level that's anywhere
below Stellar you know we're surprised
you know anytime he misses tactics on
the regular we're surprised and that's
not a knock on nihal it's actually the
opposite it's precisely because we're so
used to seeing his excellence in the SCC
particularly today was just not his day
today was a day where mvl continues to
show ridiculously good form in this
tournament
right and I'm curious if he can become a
real threat to Hikaru in the semi-finals
of course your car is going to be a big
favor but if MPL shows this form in the
semifinals he might have a chance
honestly if he plays like this I think
he absolutely has a chance I mean Hikaru
has been phenomenal Magnus has been in
ridiculously good form but mvl is just
not making a lot of mistakes as he takes
another one and with a victory in this
game this will be a double digit
Advantage for Maxime nihal has never
lost an SCC match by over five points
try that on for size
wow yeah he always manages to keep it
close even against Hikaru but it's been
an absolute blog today I mean mvl I
think it's it's a tale of two stories
like mpl's been playing great chess and
nihal has been playing slightly below
his level
no totally
this looks like a good opening for nehal
at jababa London tried it out by mvl
seven minutes remaining time for a
couple more games but mvl keeps fighting
G6 blasting through on the king side and
he's got good practical chances here I
think
yeah I like the position for MPL his
kingdom is still pretty safe and the
black king on F7 is very exposed Knight
G5 is coming on the next move
it's amazing right now the score across
all three segments is six to three how
about that obviously that's not going to
be the final score because they've got
more games to play but that's how a nine
point lead is built
exactly yes so let's see what Neil's
gonna do here maybe bishop 70 take 24
game MPL sex instantly but does this
work
Knight G5 after King G8 is what he's
banking oh no Knight G5 and queen F6
Knight H7 what is he doing Knight G5
Knight G5 wait they're going down this
repetition and the first drop
right right
ig5 literally ended the game I have no
idea what happened there but again it's
a moot point
but the first wonderful White I wonder
why King Jade was not played another
white knight if I was not played but
we'll never know we will never know that
will forever remain behind the scenes
what won't remain behind the scenes is
yet another game in this structure they
have repeated this ad nauseum it seems
yep knee-haw breaking in the sun again
with the move C4 MPL has all of oh and
this Pawn is not lost just yet but it's
very difficult to defend that for 93.
yeah
the queen D6 securing the pawn queen B3
reinforcing the attack on the pawn
it's just gonna snag it
yep it takes a five mvl banking honest
Bishops again but it should not be
enough
he's got the extra juicer maybe rotate
road to the tower over C1 bashing up on
C7 ice skated right class right triangle
97.6 which would create a double or I
don't know like the double attack on the
two Rush Road D6 therefore to stop it in
D4 okay but it opens up the chooser
yeah he's got the big white center on D5
and Rook e to C1 pressuring the bishop
this is looking promising for knee-hole
let's see if you can get one or two more
victories some honor goals to finish off
this forgettable match for any Hall and
an unforgettable one for mvl of course
yeah this is perhaps one of his most
dominant performances in the MPL he
crushed good cash in the first match but
good cash isn't necessarily known as a
speed demon but but nihal isn't that
makes this Victory all the more
impressive and to your point there are
many components to an impressive Victory
you never win a match by this margin
just because of one reason there's
always several component parts and one
of the component parts was his time
management which was impressive in the
five minute portion but even more
impressive in the three minute portion
you can basically count on one hand
the amount of times that mvl lost a game
based on time pressure he always seemed
to keep like a 30 second and 15 second
time advantage that served him so well
in those time scramble phases nihal is
going to take this one but it is a moot
point less than four minutes remaining
in the match and you can just sense the
disappointment on nihil's face in his
expressions
right and this might very easily be the
last game or the penultimate game MPL
switching it up with the Queen's gamut
and you know playing Super solid 907 but
yeah and we also played a stellar chest
today he made barely any blunders
knee-hal like you said he Austin got a
long time he even lost the game on time
here and there but the MPL has been so
consistent throughout
yeah he actually lost several by
flagging in let's say savable or even
outright equal positions and we never
see that from Newhall he always has you
know a third eye that he keeps on his
clock but today you know something just
didn't quite go right he woke up on the
wrong side of the bed and that coincided
with some of the best form that we've
seen across our years commentating the
SCC we finally have a different opening
here to round off the match it's a
queen's gamma declined with a closed
Center closed Queen side position and a
bunch of Trades
yeah black extreme is solitude but also
a little bit passive white is more space
but it's always very difficult to break
through so maybe another draw here Diane
it's possible man that's all they're
making now is draws so many draws in
this match really non-combative chess
pretty disappointing yep
right there should be seven both sides
moving back and forth okay wait Knight
takes B5 wow look at this side you can
actually sack the queen and you might
even be better that's an incredible line
but well that will also remain behind
the scenes likely we're gonna get one
more game after this one I think
yeah I like how nihal is rerouting his
pieces 96.5 putting pressure on D4 he
also controls the only open file on the
board so maybe he can score another
honorary uh Victory here
absolutely
and um
okay looks like a good position for
nehal he's also got a lot more time with
that pressure down the a file but how
does he break through here he might be
setting up alakyne's gun if he gets his
Queen to the a file no Rook A1 trying to
get off a pair of Rooks the pressure on
the D4 Pawn here might be the deciding
factor if nehal can take this one
yeah this is another typical knee-hole
game it's it's kind of disappointing for
him dying because he started off so well
he had some of those knee-haul wins like
this one where he's slowly but surely
tightening the screws not giving MPL a
chance but it was overshadowed with some
losses in time pressure
no you're exactly right and and
partially it's because mvl managed to
steer the game in the direction of
positions that he feels comfortable and
he trusted his intuition
but how the percentage with which mvl
saw crushing tactics was perhaps the
most impressive aspect of this match to
me the way that he navigated complex
positions that was something else are we
gonna get a win here for knee-haul or is
this still a draw
it looks good for Neil but is it when so
take Stakes G-Force 24 now and D4 this
is over G4 apparently was still a draw
so we are gonna avoid a draw in this
game nihal is going to promote first
and we have time for one more game
it's down to a six point match but seven
point match but it doesn't matter this
is going to be the final game folks
Maxime is gonna take this match
what a performance what a performance by
the Frenchman with three names
exactly and and I was wondering if
you're mvl here and you're trying to
lose the match do you think you you
manage or are you just not on time to
hit the result you'll resign sufficient
number of times no I actually don't
think you can I think by the time you
rematch
[Music]
[Laughter]
should just wait this out I don't think
he wants to play another game that's it
87.
she's down two pieces but he's gonna
keep playing workout faking G8 it's over
yeah oh he resigns is there still time
left or is there a match that's the
match time ran out it's a eight point
Victory a dominant display by maxiva
shillagrub across all three time
controls honestly in terms of game
quality and in terms of just the
accuracy shown throughout the match one
of the best SCC performances that I have
ever seen
yeah no great stuff by MPL he was so
consistent throughout he took advantage
of nihil's time pressure and he barely
gave him any uh like he of course gave
him some wins but he didn't give away
any unnecessary points
it was incredible it was incredible from
many different perspectives as we take a
look there at um Maxime vashay lagrav my
gosh that was so so so impressive by mvl
yeah look at that final score Daniel
across the board he was just so dominant
he took a three-point lead in the five
plus one portion he won the three plus
one portion with a three-point margin as
well and in the bullet he did not slip
up and one was a two point margin as
well
yeah I mean there were so many
impressive games like looking through
the match there were so many moments
where eviel just did a much better job
than his opponent of navigating the
complexities of the position and they
had a lot of complex positions they had
a lot of positions in which it would
have been so easy to slip up so easy to
blunder and yet mvl ultimately managed
to navigate all of those situations it's
time for our coinbase it's time for a
coinbase Savvy move of the day we've got
so much to choose from I'm just gonna
pull up one of the one of the many games
uh in which mvl displayed his acumen
okay maybe we can take this game I mean
there were just so many moments it's so
hard to choose
um I don't know I'll be out here
Benjamin I I'm having a hard time
choosing a game
right um yeah so uh he played great
throughout the match but I think his
most impressive one was
we saw how it was so back and forth with
Diane I think we should start right here
the position is extremely complicated
and nehal has just played the move Queen
to F3 hitting the pawn on the four and
instead of Defending it he plays the
move Rook to D7 attacking the Knight on
F5 if you're taking a four there's
Bishop G3 you block the check and attack
the Knight once more so nihal played the
Knight E4 hitting the bishop on F2 but
now MV Ultra stakes in a seven with a
check the king steps up and now Bishop
to H4 and there's nothing you can do to
stop Bishop to G5 check in case you go
G5 y takes the pawn the queen is hanging
as well and wide wins so that was your
Savvy Mo move of the day presented by
coinbase and what made that game so
impressive was the way that he turned
that game around earlier on he was
losing for most of the game and he was
basically doing what we're used to
seeing nihal sarin do turn games around
navigate tactics playing really quickly
throughout there just weren't a lot of
time scrambles in this match and that is
one thing that I was expecting
throughout all of the segments I thought
that we'd have time scram left or time
scramble nihal was the one who was
sitting in time pressure for most of the
match Benjamin super impressive
performance
and a really impressive performance by
MPL he always kept the lead in the clock
and that's why he managed to trick nihal
a game after game
absolutely and we will hear the Victor's
thoughts we will set up Maxima
shellegrav for an interview and we will
take it to a break we congratulate the
Frenchman with three names for one of
the most impressive SCC performances an
interview with mvl won the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
returns in a few
[Music]
thank you
so now we're going to try the air things
memory Fest two years ago in 2021 I
tested magnus's memory by setting up a
bunch of famous positions and seeing
whether he could recognize them
this is the 24th game from Seville
obviously now we're going to do the same
but with an added twist we're not even
going to be able to see which pieces are
which every piece will be represented by
an air things device instead so let's
see how Magnus gets on
foreign
first of all I'm thinking like what are
all these pawns on the last strength but
if I'm going to go piece by piece I'm
hoping that this is a king and these are
pawns and that this is a bishop and
hopefully Queen H6 should be made in two
2016 right yes Carlson against karyakin
so this test is called has mine has been
following the world championship ding is
White against the Premiership and here
he could have taken the Rook with the
queen eventually green goes back here
and eventually the king is
running away things should have found
this thing
is this any more difficult for you uh no
not really the games are too famous
that's the problem this has to be uh to
Paulo from 99 in RS what characteristics
make you recognize this position maybe
like it's just the structure on the
queen side nice
thank you
so this one is one of my happier early
chess chess memories it's from the world
youth Championship under 14. I'm playing
Black in the first round against the
future Grandmaster Hammer that's the
king over there this and this this
checkmates
this looks like checkers
so few pieces
but it's definitely a game I've seen
yeah
almost it's
I don't want to give it away but it you
will have that's the clue you will have
seen it
I'm not sure I should have seen this
okay
in that case I apologize
uh it's from the Queen's Gambit TV show
when Beth plays what's his name towns in
the first her first ever tournament oh
is it and this is a rook and it's
trapped now because there's a nice and
D4 and a king on D2 ah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember that sequence from from
the series now but like it was I wasn't
even close to be honest
[Music]
yeah
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
just witnessed a dominant performance
two dominant performances actually as
Magnus Carlson defeats nepo in the
morning but today right now is all about
the Frenchman with three names Maxima
shiligrav with a commanding victory over
nihal sarin to propel himself further in
the speed Chess Championship and setup a
match against hikaranakamura Maxime
thank you so much for joining us for a
quick interview you started with a one
point deficit and you never looked back
can you tell us a little bit about what
you think changed after the first 30
minutes of the five plus one portion to
allow you to score this commanding
victory
every game was white
which really didn't make so much sense
but uh
it was just one of those days where
white was uh
uh completely dominant and some like
scored a couple of crucial pictures with
black cannons
then I got some leads but of course it
could have been a much closer matter
like uh
I think a few of these games I won in
GLE stages uh I had is there an equal
position or even worse positions so
the first four games of course it's not
the same story
all right and mvl you've played in quite
a lot of secs already how did you use
your experience that you've gathered
over the years and how would you use
that in your upcoming semi-final match
against Hikaru
I mean I just place or like I don't
really
I don't really care like um
just fighting it's good fights good fun
in general the past few hours of Chess
uh I even remember the old days where it
was three hours of of Chess without a
single break so
you know it feels much easier of course
with the brakes
um and you know I you know just to dwell
you just want to to get pressure on your
opponents and
yeah somehow I managed but today of
course against Eco will be built very
very difficult story
I've never won uh with the cow I think I
played at least three times
and this format is obviously one of the
two dominant players
there was Magnus
and one like
four or five maybe more of them
Awards or it would be a very very
challenging task but
I'll need to be much more solid with
black I feel like because I don't think
I can work up
is that many points with weights against
the code
maximum let me follow up on that before
we uh ask you a few chat questions do
you think there is a high likelihood
that Hikaru repeats his opening
Shenanigans against you or are you
expecting more conventional opening
choices
uh I'll let him do whatever Essence is
correct
so you know I'll be prepared for any
Shenanigans but
um you know I it's not
um like easy to even predict because I I
didn't
think you would uh it would do it at all
either against you again here or against
Fabi so you know
maybe you'll do it maybe you won't but
yeah
I want to sleep over that
or that source
yeah we'll see what he's going to cook
up in in his match against you and Maxim
I was wondering what did you do in terms
of preparation for this match against
nihal
I mean I just look briefly with black
um you know I'd like to play in this
grandfathers and so on but uh actually
like I didn't really predict
um that you would go for this C3 line I
thought it would go for something else
uh it's related to B3
so that's why I had trouble going the
first few games before I realized
somehow maybe a way to play or so it was
a bit shaky anyhow and with white I
realized it would be too difficult to
predict I expected something without us
but you know then petrol feeds and one
character and so on so like
I wasn't too concerned about what would
happen is why it's like I I didn't think
it would be a huge theoretical duel
although it was kind of in the patron
I've seen one more question for me Bruce
Mack asks what is your favorite time
control between five plus one three plus
one and one plus one which one do you
consider to be your strongest
it's difficult to say oh no
I guess three plus one is another one uh
we're most used to
um
but I don't know I I used a
uh okay still play fast but I feel like
I was playing faster I used to play
faster so let's say three plus one is a
good you know
it's a good intermediate example for me
and of course against equivalent I
cannot expect to dominate in one plus
one
uh that's definitely uh
uh one of the time format where you can
Works absolutely anyone
and that's quite badly so you know I'll
be
looking to try to make a difference in
the first two that controls but that's
not gonna be easy of course
for sure and Maxim another check
question by Bruce Mac he was wondering
do you play pause rush to prepare for
events like this
sometimes I do yeah I didn't really
I just
[Music]
um
I just did a few puzzles maybe one hour
before I actually solved like someone
nine out of 10 which
is like
totally exceptional
because
I usually uh I'm taking off time and
make mistakes of some mistake so
I did feel like I was in
like I had good tactical Vision today
and I think it did happen in the
matching it didn't need to to create
that help
Maxime we know it's late for you you
just played an incredible match and put
everything on the chessboard we will let
you rest thank you for your Insight best
of luck against icaro we're looking
forward to that match
thank you
all right the Frenchman with three names
another entry into his impressive array
of SCC victories 88 average accuracy a
victory by eight points it was a
knee-hole sarin's day and his mediocre
form Benjamin just happened to
correspond with some of the best form
that we have seen across the years in
the SEC
yeah let's have a look at our post-match
analytics we see that MPL scored an
average accuracy of 88 Nils accuracy
wasn't even that low dying but he also
lost the game on Time One game by
disconnect overall MPL is just a more
consistent player
he most certainly was there were so many
different aspects to his Mastery today
he played positionally tactically he was
fixing opening problems as the match was
going on definitely something for the
other SEC participants to take
inspiration from things didn't look
amazing right off the bat but MPL kept
fighting and obviously speaking of
amazing we've had other amazing
performances as we look at the brackets
the SEC semifinals are now set we will
have Hikaru against mvl and another
classic battle between Carlson and
Wesley so these are going to be two epic
unmissable matches so mark your
calendars right now folks these two
semi-finals are going to be one for the
ages who will make it to the final
Benjamin impossible to say will we get
another Nakamura Carlson match
that is I mean the most like they are
definitely the favorites to make it
there but mvl if he continues his form
from today against Hikaru he definitely
has a shot Wesley I think he also has a
shot Magnus said he hasn't been playing
in his greatest form so if Wesley brings
the A-game and Magnus brings his b or c
game there can also be a close affair
while the match will be happening
Tuesday at 2 p.m New York time 11 A.M in
San Francisco and at 8 pm central
European Standard Time Carlson so
unmissable action a reprisal of their
many many matches during the covet era
oh my gosh Benjamin mouth-watering
today's matches were mouth-watering as
well I just wanted to commend you
Benjamin as we wrap up this show for
eight nine hours of commentary you were
a trooper today and you brought the
energy until the very end it was a
pleasure covering this match with you
and I will give you the mic one more
time for your final thoughts on today's
day of action
it was a lot of fun covering the matches
with you today and also with our good
friend Robert Hassel yeah it it's it's
been a lot of fun Diane I can I cannot
wait for the semifinals
I can't wait for it either before we
wrap up today's show one more quick PSA
folks remember that it is that time of
year September through the end of this
month claim up to 30 off on all new Subs
on Twitch subscribers gain access to
exclusive breakdown content during
broadcast unlock new emotes with Danny's
various Expressions mittens and even
nepo and score an ad free experience on
chess.com don't miss out on deals this
September subscribe now and on that note
folks we'd like to thank our amazing
production team for their hard work
their indefatigable efforts in making
our job easy another shout out to you
Benjamin as well as to everybody in the
chat we had over 10 000 of you on Twitch
and on YouTube cheering on your favorite
player and making the SCC the magical
event that it is every year and on that
note Grandmaster Daniel meriditsky and
Grandmaster Benjamin Bach reminding you
that the next match is coming your way
on Tuesday between Carlson and so and
for now bidding you a great great rest
of your Friday and a good weekend from
the speed Chess Championship presented
by coinbase goodbye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]